Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. Or, if you're listening on the Apple Podcasts app, you can subscribe within the app in just a few clicks. Right, lads. Now, I know there's not a faint heart among you,
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区吗？请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。感谢收听《历史的余烬》。想要收听加更节目、抢先体验、无广告音频并加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。或者，如果您使用的是苹果播客（Apple Podcasts）应用，只需点击几下即可在应用内订阅。好了，伙计们。现在，我知道你们中间没有懦夫，
and I know you're as anxious as I am to get into close action. Do you want to see a guillotine in Piccadilly? Do you want to call that raggedy-ass Napoleon your king? Do you want your children to sing the Marseillaise? England is under threat of invasion, and though we be on the far side of the world, this podcast is our home. This podcast is England. So as every hand to his rope or gun, quicks the word and sharps the action. After all, Tom Holland, history is on our side.
我知道你们和一样渴望投入近距离战斗。你想在皮卡迪利大街看到断头台吗？你想叫那个衣衫褴褛的拿破仑为你的国王吗？你想让你的孩子们唱《马赛曲》吗？英格兰正面临入侵的威胁，尽管我们身处世界的另一端，但这个播客就是我们的家。这个播客就是英格兰。所以，当每一双手握住缆绳或火枪，迅捷是口令，精准是行动。毕竟，汤姆·霍兰德，历史站在我们这边。
Now, that was, of course, Russell Crowe as Captain Jack Aubrey in the film Master and Commander, adapted from the novels of Patrick O'Brien. Tom Holland, would you agree that that film as a portrait of French history is right up there with The Pink Panther Strikes Again? I knew you were going to mention Inspector Clouseau. This is what I was expecting. So today we are doing A History of France in 10 Films. And Dominic, you messaged me and said
好了，那当然是罗素·克劳在电影《怒海争锋：极地远征》中饰演的杰克·奥布里船长，该片改编自帕特里克·奥布里安的小说。汤姆·霍兰德，你是否同意这部电影作为法国历史的写照，完全可以与《粉红豹再次出击》相媲美？我就知道你要提克鲁索探长。我就料到你会这么说。所以今天我们要盘点的是“通过10部电影看法国法国历史”。多米尼克，你给我发信息说
you got a brilliant introduction. A world-class introduction. And I knew it was going to feature Clouseau. Right. And it did, if only obliquely. Very obliquely. But you didn't expect Captain Jack Aubrey, did you? My superb Russell Crowe voice.
你准备了一个精彩的开场白。一个世界级的开场白。我就知道里面肯定会有克鲁索。没错。确实有，哪怕只是隐晦地提到。非常隐晦。但你没想到会有杰克·奥布里船长吧？我模仿得绝佳的罗素·克劳嗓音。
Yeah, you know, some bloke with rope. You always try and bring him in. Right. But anyway, Tom um films in france are they're kind of synonymous aren't they in the anglo-saxon imagination um france is one of the great homes of of cinema and actually films are a really fun way to think about french history don't you agree we absolutely more i i'm looking forward to the deployment of your French accent in this podcast. So, Tom, we have with us the film critic Muriel Zaga, who has written and broadcasted widely about French cinema.
对，你知道的，某个拿着绳子的家伙。你总是试图把他带进来。好吧。但不管怎样，汤姆，嗯，法国的电影，它们在盎格鲁-萨克逊人的想象中可以说是一种代名词，对吧？嗯，法国是电影的伟大发源地之一，实际上，电影是思考法国历史的一种非常有趣的方式，你不觉得吗？绝对是的，我……我非常期待在这个播客中听到你大显身手，秀出你的法国口音。所以，汤姆，我们今天请来了影评人穆里尔·扎加（Muriel Zaga），她曾广泛撰文并播讲关于法国电影的内容。
Muriel, bienvenue. Thank you for joining us. You presumably do want to see a guillotine and picadilly, but we'll gloss over that. Yeah. So France, the home of cinema, do you think? Is that fair to say? I mean, American listeners would be outraged by this, but do you think you would call France the home of cinema?
穆里尔，欢迎。谢谢你加入我们。你大概确实很想在皮卡迪利大街看到断头台吧，不过我们就略过不谈了。是的。所以法国，电影的发源地，你觉得呢？这样说公平吗？我的意思是，美国听众可能会对此感到愤怒，但你觉得你会称法国为电影的发源地吗？
Well, yes, that's a long-running dispute whether Americans invented cinema or the French. I'm going to say the French did. I'm going to say French cinema is almost sort of playonistic, you know. But I would say that, wouldn't I? But partly because I think the French take cinema seriously. It's entertainment for everyone, but it is also an art form. So perhaps that's why they own it. We own it. That's a claim, isn't it, Tom?
嗯，是的，这是一个长期存在的争论，究竟是美国人还是法国人发明了电影。我会说是法国人。我要说“法国电影”几乎算是一种同义反复，你知道的。不过我当然会这么说，不是吗？但部分原因是因为我认为法国人对待电影非常认真。它是属于所有人的娱乐，但它同时也是一种艺术形式。所以也许这就是为什么他们拥有它。我们拥有它。这可真敢说，不是吗，汤姆？
So do you think, I mean, here in England, we often say people learn more about history from Hollywood films, I mean, terrible Hollywood films often, than they do through the written word. Is that true in France as well? I don't know. I mean, the huge question is whether history can can actually be taught through film it's people certainly um confirm their national narrative through watching films so perhaps things they've been taught at school are then reinforced on the screen. The teaching of history is changing in France. That's another thing, of course, is that sometimes for the younger generation,
所以你觉得，我的意思是，在英国这里，我们经常说人们从好莱坞电影中——我的意思是，通常是糟糕的好莱坞电影——学到的历史知识，比通过文字阅读学到的还要多。法国也是如此吗？我不知道。我的意思是，一个巨大的问题是，历史是否真的可以通过电影来教授。人们当然是通过观看电影来巩固他们的国家叙事，所以也许他们在学校里学到的东西随后在银幕上得到了强化。法国的历史教学正在发生变化。当然，还有另一件事，那就是有时对于年轻一代来说，
possibly they will learn about absolutely essential events of French history through film or television for the first time, because these things simply won't have been covered at school. Yeah. And so we have asked you to compile a history of France through 10 films, which is a very, very tough ask. I thank you for this nightmarish challenge. So I'm very much looking forward to you choosing Asterix and Obelix as your first choice. So I'm very much looking forward to you choosing Asterix and Obelix as your first choice. So I'm assuming that will be your first choice. Will it? It's not my first choice because, well, okay, several reasons.
他们可能会通过电影或电视第一次了解到法国历史上绝对至关重要的事件，因为这些事情在学校里根本不会被涵盖。是的。所以我们请你通过10部电影来编纂一部法国史，这是一个非常非常艰巨的要求。谢谢你给我出了这个噩梦般的挑战。所以我非常期待你选择《阿斯特里克斯历险记》作为你的第一选择。所以我非常期待你选择《阿斯特里克斯历险记》作为你的第一选择。所以我假设那将是你的第一选择。会是吗？这不是我的第一选择，因为，好吧，原因有几个。
The books are better. The books are better than the film adaptation. So really, you're better off reading and rereading the books, which are very rich and very well historically informed. In terms of early French history or history of the Gaulois, there isn't a whole lot of films to pick from, partly because it's still a very obscure part of our history. And also my contention is that it's because the French have an inferiority complex because of the Romans, because the Romans are so crushingly glamorous on film. And it's very difficult for Hirsute Gaulle's to compete with that. So I'm just going to start with a counter example. I mean mean an example of a have not to do
原著书更好。原著书比电影改编版更好。所以实际上，你最好还是去读一读、重读那些书，它们内容非常丰富，历史考证也非常扎实。就早期法国历史或高卢人历史而言，其实没有太多电影可供挑选，部分原因是因为这段历史对我们来说仍然非常模糊；另一个我的观点是，这是因为法国人对罗马人有着自卑情结，因为罗马人在电影中的形象实在是压倒性地光芒四射。高卢男子那种毛发浓密的形象很难与之竞争。所以我先从一个反面例子开始。我的意思是，举一个
French historical film about that period it's unkind to talk about it but at the same time it's worth mentioning there was in the early 2000s a film about Vincent Jeterix the chieftain of the Arvenians is that we call them the Arvenians and this starred Christophe Lambert
关于那个时期的法国历史电影的“反面教材”——虽然谈论这个有点不厚道，但同时又值得一提。大约在2000年代初，有一部关于阿维尔尼人的首领维钦托利的电影——我们是这么叫他们的吗？阿维尔尼人——主演是克里斯托弗·兰伯特。
oh dear yes I know no exactly yes oh dear so there is a thing it's it's awful really there's a thing called the golden bidet so appropriately the opposite of a cesar i guess exactly exactly right exactly right so this film garnered three of those one for the film worst film one for worst director and i won't mention his name it's kinder i really want to see the worst actor christopher can take it well you can find it on youtube so go go and have a you know fun afternoon there's no way you could have a film about versingatrix winning a cesar so i i think that that is well that's the thing so the problem with
哦，天哪，是的，我懂，不，完全是的，哦，天哪。所以确实有这么个东西，它真的很糟糕。有一个奖叫“金尿盆奖”，正如人们所料，我猜它刚好跟恺撒奖（César）相反。完全正确，完全正确，一点没错。所以这部电影囊括了其中三个奖项：一个是最烂电影，一个是最烂导演——我就不提他的名字了，这样比较仁慈，我真的很想看最烂演员。克里斯托弗能坦然接受这一切。你可以在YouTube上找到它，所以去度过一个充满欢乐的下午吧。你绝不可能看到一部关于维钦托利获恺撒奖的电影。所以我想这大概就是——所以问题在于，
the film is microscopic budget very i mean huge ambition but no writing the acting is terrible everything just inexplicable facial hair it's a very hirsute hairy film anyway so this is the problem is that uh doing historical reconstitutions costs a lot of money and by and large french directors and producers don't have access to Hollywood-style budgets. So I think you can only tackle early or early-ish French history if you have a sort of minimalist sensibility, like Robert Bresson, for example, who did make a film about Joan of Arc. I'm not going to talk about him. I'm going to talk about another film about Joan of Arc. So we are going to leap in seven-league boots right over Clovis, Charlemagne, everybody, and go straight
这部电影预算微乎其微，我的意思是，野心勃勃却缺乏剧本，演技糟糕透顶，一切都莫名其妙，面部毛发更是让人费解，总之这是一部毛发非常浓密的电影。不管怎样，这就是问题所在，呃，进行历史重现需要花费大量的资金，而法国的导演和制片人们大体上并没有好莱坞式的预算。所以我觉得，只有当你拥有某种极简主义美学时，才能着手拍摄早期或较早期的法国历史，比如罗伯特·布列松（Robert Bresson），他确实拍过一部关于圣女贞德的电影。我不打算谈他。我要谈另一部关于圣女贞德的电影。所以我们将迈着七里靴大步流星，直接跨过克洛维、查理曼大帝所有人，径直来到
to Joan of Arc because she is really the first figure, I think, really to crystallize national identity up to the present day. So she remains a really important foundational figure. And it is fitting that she's a woman because, of course, the Republic is a woman, liberté, égalité, fraternité, Marianne, all of these are potentially female allegories. Dominique, I've never heard of her, have we, Dominique? Never, never, never. I can't believe the French tried to pass the sauce off as the champions of liberty, Thomas. Anyway, go on, Muriel. Don't let us put you off there have been no never never keep going there have been many many films about joan of arc understandably because she's a i mean it's a word but she's an iconic figure obviously that lends itself herself to to screen treatment she's
圣女贞德，因为她真的是第一个真正将民族认同凝聚并延续至当代的历史人物。因此，她至今仍是一个极其重要的奠基人物。而且她是一位女性非常合情合理，因为共和国本身就是女性——自由、平等、博爱，玛丽安娜，所有这些都具有女性的寓意。多米尼克，我们从来没听说过她，对吧，多米尼克？从未，从未，从未。真不敢相信法国人试图把这酱料冒充为自由的捍卫者，托马斯。总之，说下去，穆里尔。别让我们打消你的积极性。从来没有，从来没有，继续说。关于圣女贞德的电影已经有很多很多了，这是可以理解的，因为她是一个——我的意思是，很难找到一个词，但她显然是一个标志性的形象，非常适合被搬上银幕。她
been played by many famous actresses the film i've chosen i like particularly because it has some of those qualities of simplicity and austerity that I think are needed if you're going to try and evoke the Middle Ages on screen without a lot of money. So this is a film that was made by Jacques Rivette. Jacques Rivette is one of the directors who made his name with the Nouvelle Vague. And he worked all his life. He died recently a few years ago. And this is a film he made in the 90s, starring an actress called Sandrine Bonner in the part of Joan. So it's a two-part epic. It's very long.
曾被许多著名的女演员扮演过。我选择这部电影是因为我特别喜欢它具有某种质朴和苦行僧般的特质，我认为如果要在没有大量资金的情况下在银幕上展现中世纪，这些特质是必不可少的。所以这是一部由雅克·里维特（Jacques Rivette）执导的电影。雅克·里维特是凭借法国新浪潮（Nouvelle Vague）成名的导演之一。他一生都在拍电影。他不久前去世了，几年前。这是他在90年代拍的一部电影，由一位名叫桑德里娜·博内尔（Sandrine Bonnaire）的女演员饰演贞德。所以这是一部两部分的史诗片。它非常长。
It's five hours long, I think. So a bit of a commitment, you know, if our listeners are thinking of watching it. You can watch it in bits, of course. You don't have to watch it all at once. It's in two parts. It's called Joan the Maid, The Battles. And then the second part is Joan the Maid, the Prisons. And so it follows the whole arc of her journey.
我想有五个小时长。所以如果我们的听众考虑观看它，这需要下一点决心。当然，你可以分段观看。你不必一次性看完。它分为两部分。第一部分叫《贞德：战斗》，第二部分叫《贞德：囚徒》。它展现了她整段旅程的轨迹。
And what I like about it is, I suppose, it's Nouvelle Vague qualities. That's to say, lots of natural light, lots of natural settings, lots of movement, and almost a sort of Western quality. So she's almost like Calamity Joan. She's often riding through these medieval French wilderness, immense sort of plains. And the battle scenes are minimal, are done with minimal number of actors, but they feel a little bit like the storming of Fort Apache. There is a really kinetic quality in the film
我喜欢它的地方在于，我想，是它的新浪潮特质。也就是说，大量的自然光，大量的实景拍摄，大量的运动，几乎带有一种西部片的特质。所以她几乎就像灾难简（Calamity Jane）。她经常骑马穿过这些中世纪的法国荒野，广袤的平原。战斗场景极简，只用了极少量的演员，但它们给人的感觉有点像《搜索者》里进攻阿帕奇堡的场面。这部电影具有非常强的动感，
and also some very beautiful, dramatic monologues to camera because it is a little bit experimental. So that's by Joan and some other characters. And Muriel, how did he do the visions, the angels? Ah, okay, very interesting. I know why you're, yes. So he doesn't, he doesn't do the visions
而且还有一些非常美丽、戏剧性的面对镜头的独白，因为它稍微有一点实验性。这是由贞德和其他一些角色完成的。穆里尔，他是怎么处理那些神迹和天使的？啊，好的，非常有趣。我知道你为什么，是的。所以他没有，他没有展现那些神迹，
and that might be disappointing why you're, yes. So he doesn't, he doesn't do the visions and that might be disappointing for you and other people. What he does instead is it's all internalized because Bonner is such an amazing performer. So she has a face that has it all in terms of Joan of Arc, I think she has severity, purity, determination, courage, you know, all of that, but she also looks a little bit sort of lit from within. And so she talks about her visions and she talks about being from God and having direct contact with God, which, of course, is why she's a heretic in the eyes of the church. But you don't see the visions. You know of them.
这可能对你和其他人来说会有点失望。他所做的是，这一切都是内化的，因为博内尔是一位如此惊艳的演员。所以她拥有一张完美契合贞德的面孔，我认为她具备了严肃、纯洁、坚决、勇气，你知道，所有这些特质，但她看起来也仿佛内心隐隐发光。因此她谈到自己的神迹，谈到自己来自上帝并与上帝有直接联系，当然，这也是为什么她在教会眼中是个异端。但你并没有看到那些神迹。你知道它们存在。
Everybody knows of them. So you have to imagine, you have to sort of join the dots in your head and imagine what's going on in her head. The spiritual dimension of her story is only under the surface. It's for you to fill in. And is it quite a, so it's quite a recent film, but is it as patriotic as it were, as previous renditions of the story of Joan of Arc would you say or is it more revisionist so that's interesting yes in some ways it's not openly
所有人都知道。所以你必须去想象，你必须在脑海中把这些点连接起来，想象她脑海中在想什么。她故事的灵性维度仅仅潜藏在水面之下。这需要由你来填补。那么这是一部相当，所以它是一部相当新的电影，但它像以往对贞德故事的演绎那样充满爱国主义色彩吗，你觉得，还是它更具修正主义色彩？这很有趣，是的。在某些方面，它并不是公开的
revisionist what it's doing I think is is reclaiming her from the the side that had taken possession of her at the time in the 90s which was was the National Front. So Joan, there's a tug of war throughout French history, starting in the 19th century, more or less, but between, say, the anti-clerical Republicans on the one side and the royalist monarchists on the other. So both parties are trying to claim Joan for themselves. Then there comes a point where she becomes really a Republican heroine. Then she is a central figure under the Vichy regime. She's reclaimed by Vichy. Then again, the Communist Party reclaim her as a sort of resistance figure after the war. All of this
修正主义，我认为它所做的是将她从当时（90年代）已经占据她的那个阵营手中夺回来，也就是国民阵线。所以在法国历史上一直有一场拉锯战，始于19世纪左右，大致在反教权的共和派和保皇派君主制支持者之间。双方都试图把贞德据为己有。后来到了某个节点，她真正成为了一个共和派女英雄。接着在维希政权时期，她成为了核心人物，被维希政权利用。再后来，战后共产党人又将她奉为抵抗运动的象征。所有这些
goes on. And then Le Pen claims her in the 60s, 70s, and she becomes associated with the National Front. And so I think what Rivette is doing, Rivette is a man of the left, broadly speaking, as most of those Nouvelle Vague directors are, is reclaiming her for the mainstream and saying she has no political colour. She is a heroine for everyone. So Myrna, the most recent Joan of Arc film I saw was by Bruno Dumont, who is a kind of enfant terrible, isn't he? Did you see that, the Joan of Arc film? I didn't see the film. I saw the clip you sent me. So it's in English, The Childhood of Joan of Arc.
都在上演。然后在60、70年代，勒庞宣称她是其代表，她开始与国民阵线联系在一起。所以我认为里维特所做的——里维特大致来说是一个左翼人士，就像大多数新浪潮导演一样——是把她重新收编回主流，并宣称她没有任何政治色彩。她是属于所有人的女英雄。所以穆里尔，我最近看的一部贞德电影是布鲁诺·杜蒙（Bruno Dumont）拍的，他算是个怪才导演，不是吗？你看过那部贞德电影吗？我没看过电影。我看了你发给我的片段。那是英语的，叫《贞德的童年》。
And you talked about the need to do films on budgets. This, I mean, this must have cost about, I should think, 37 euros. I mean, it's a girl wandering around a load of sandbanks and it's very, very odd. And the music, it's kind of, it's a musical basically. And I just wanted to play, I don't know whether we're allowed to do this, whether we'll get in trouble with the copyright, but this is a sequence where Joan of Arc is, she's a a little girl she's walking up a sandbank and suddenly these two nuns appear and start talking to her about the nature of christ so uh can you hear that it's associated with guns and N' Roses or something?
你刚才提到需要以有限的预算拍电影。这部电影，我的意思是，它大概只花了37欧元吧。我的意思是，就是一个女孩在沙洲上走来走去，非常非常诡异。而且音乐，它基本上是一部音乐剧。我只想放一段——我不知道我们能不能这样做，会不会惹上版权麻烦——但这是一个场景，贞德还是个小女孩，她走上沙洲，突然这两个修女出现，开始跟她谈论基督的本质，所以，呃，你能听到吗？这让人联想到枪与玫瑰乐队（Guns N' Roses）之类的东西？
It's weirdly effective, but kind of like nothing I've ever seen before. And I quite recommend it. Tom, if the budget really was 37 euros, you're very unlikely to be harassed by their lawyers. That's probably true. And it's worth it also for Joan's vision of um saint michael and the two saints which is excellent i won't i won't spoil it yes how are the um how are the english portrayed in jean lapucelle um are they are they villainous and um is that a hollywood style portrait yes no they are they are they are utterly villainous so they're called uh les godons i think was the word the medieval word that the french used at
它有一种诡异的成效，但几乎是我从未见过的。我非常推荐它。汤姆，如果预算真的只有37欧元，你们不太可能会遭到他们律师的骚扰。那可能确实如此。而且这部电影也值得一看，尤其是贞德关于圣米迦勒和两位圣人的幻视非常棒，我不剧透了，是的。在《贞德》（La Pucelle）中，英国人的形象是怎么被刻画的？他们是反派吗，这是一种好莱坞式的描绘吗？是的，不，他们是，他们是彻头彻尾的反派。所以他们被称为“Les Godons”，我想这是中世纪法国人当时用的一个词，
the time which is a bit like the han for the you know the germans um during a different war they are cruel uh sadistic coarse beyond belief um really no redeeming features at all please oh this sounds terrible i think we boycott that. So, that's Joan of Arc. So, what is number two on your list? So, number two, again, we are leaping because we need to. We're leaping to The Wars of Religion and La Reine Margot. Ah, yes. Oh, yes.
这有点像在另一场战争中德国人被叫作“汉（Hun）”一样。他们残酷、虐待成性、粗鲁得不可思议，真的没有任何救赎的特质。哦，听起来太糟糕了，我想我们要抵制那部电影。好，这就是圣女贞德。那么你清单上的第二部是什么？好，第二部，我们再次进行跨越，因为我们需要这样做。我们跨越到了宗教战争和《玛戈王后》（La Reine Margot）。啊，是的。哦，是的。
Isabella Gianni. Yes, yes. Yes. So, this is an early 90s movie they are actually both from around the same time the uh the Joan of Arc and the and La Reine Margot which is La Reine Margot is based on the novel by Alexandre Dumas called La Reine Margot and he of course also wrote The Three Musketeers which is perhaps a novel that will be better known in England. So it's really more an adaptation of the novel than a serious piece of historical research. But that makes it really
伊莎贝尔·阿佳妮（Isabella Adjani）。是的，是的。对。所以这是一部90年代初的电影，实际上这两部电影大约都在同一时期，贞德和《玛戈王后》，后者是根据亚历山大·小仲马（Alexandre Dumas）名为《玛戈王后》的小说改编的。他当然还写过《三个火枪手》，这在英国或许是一部更广为人知的小说。所以与其说它是严肃的历史研究，不如说它更多是对小说的改编。但这使得它变得非常
fun because it's a really revolutionary take on the historical movie. So in a sense, it's a film about the 19th century as well as about the 16th century, would that be fair? That's the thing, is that there are endless layers wherever you look, because everything is always has a context of its own. It's looking back at different versions. It's a revision of something that came before. So yes, it's based on all kinds of 19th century ideas about Marguerite de Valois. So we get everything, you know, in a way, what it resembles mostly, or foreshadows, is Game of Thrones. It is very sexy and very violent, very gory. And there is nudity, which of course, you'd expect in a French film. But even then, it was pushing the boundaries.
有趣，因为它对历史电影进行了革命性的诠释。所以从某种意义上说，这是一部关于19世纪的电影，同时也是关于16世纪的电影，这样说公平吗？正是如此，无论你从哪个角度看，它都有无数的层次，因为每件事物总是拥有它自己的语境。它是在回看不同的版本，是对之前事物的修正。所以是的，它是基于对瓦卢瓦的玛格丽特的各种19世纪的观念。所以我们看到了这一切，你知道，在某种程度上，它最像或者说预示的是《权力的游戏》。它非常性感，非常暴力，非常血腥。而且里面有裸露镜头，当然，这是你在法国电影中会期待的。但即便如此，它当时也突破了界限。
And so Margot is represented with all the sort of legends associated with her run in facts. That's to say she's an infomaniac. She has probably incestuous relationships with her brothers. And then in a famous final scene, which is lifted from Stendhal's The Scarlet and the Black black actually it's mentioned in that novel in a romantic final image she sits with her lover's severed head bloody bleeding severed head in her lap and that's that's the last we see of her and all those things are probably completely invented and some some people say Protestant propaganda.
所以玛戈的形象被塑造成带有各种围绕着她流传的传奇色彩。也就是说，她是个性欲狂。她可能与她的兄弟们有乱伦关系。然后在一个著名的结尾场景中，实际上是从司汤达的《红与黑》中借鉴过来的——在小说的一个浪漫结局意象中，她怀里抱着她情人的血淋淋、血肉模糊的首级，那是我们对她最后的印象。而所有这些事情可能完全都是虚构的，有些人说这是新教徒的宣传。
You know, there are things that are featured. Well, Dominic's a big fan of Protestant propaganda. I'm all about Protestant propaganda on this podcast. So for those listeners who don't know, it's set in the late 16th century, and it's the period when Catholics and Protestants are kind of fighting for control of France. And I guess one of the centerpieces
你知道，里面有一些这样的情节。好吧，多米尼克是新教徒宣传的超级粉丝。我在这档播客里全盘接受新教徒的宣传。所以对于那些不知道的听众来说，它的背景设定在16世纪后期，那是天主教徒和新教徒为争夺法国控制权而战的时期。我猜其中一个核心场景
is the massacre of St. Bartholomew's Day, which even people who don't know much French history will probably have very vaguely heard of when it's the Huguenots who get massacred, isn't it? It is. And is there any, I mean, this is a pretty dumb question, I suppose, but is there any sort of, do these things have any traction in france now i mean do people care at all about the the wars of religion and the huguenots and and all that kind of thing or is it just ancient history a little bit of both it's very remote i mean i do remember for example from my own days in primary school being taught about the swiss called the massacre de la saint-barthélemy
是圣巴托洛缪大屠杀，即便是不太了解法国历史的人可能也模模糊糊地听说过，那是胡格诺派遭到屠杀的事件，对吧？正是如此。这有没有——我的意思是，这大概是个挺蠢的问题，不过这些事情在现在的法国还有任何吸引力吗？我的意思是，人们还在乎宗教战争、胡格诺派以及诸如此类的事情吗，还是说这纯粹已经是古代历史了？两者皆有吧，这非常遥远。我的意思是，我确实记得比如在我的小学时代，被教导过关于所谓“圣巴托洛缪大屠杀”的法语词汇，
french and i don't think i knew really then what Protestants were. You know, it was very abstract. So I think unless, and that's probably still true nowadays, that unless you are a French Protestant, because there are some left, not very many, but there are, there are some, and still some very powerful families, then you will probably feel the episode quite viscerally. The majority of people have probably forgotten that there ever was a serious challenge to Catholicism in France, I think.
当时我大概并不真的知道什么是新教徒。你知道，这非常抽象。所以我想，除非——而且现在可能依然如此——除非你是一个法国新教徒，因为确实还有一些，虽然不多，但确实有，而且还有一些非常有权势的家族，否则你大概不会对这段插曲有什么切肤之感。大多数人可能已经忘记法国曾经存在过对天主教的严重挑战了，我是说。
A serious Calvinist challenge. Lionel Jospin was a Protestant, wasn't he? I think Michel Rocard also was a Protestant. And people always mentioned it. People did say, oh, Rocard, who of course is a Protestant, you know, as if somehow it meant something. But they're not still called Huguenots? No. Okay. No. So that scene, the massacre scene, because it's very Game of Thrones, is incredibly hair-raising and dreadful. So it does actually bring home just how horrible, bloodthirsty, grislyly barbaric the whole thing was and there are afterwards and the aftermath in a way is worse it's piles of naked bodies on cars just horrific i i saw that film about 30 years ago i hadn't really thought of it till you i till you brought
一个严重的加尔文主义挑战。利昂内尔·若斯潘（Lionel Jospin）是新教徒，对吧？我想米歇尔·罗卡尔（Michel Rocard）也是新教徒。人们总是会提到这一点。人们会说，“哦，罗卡尔，他当然是个新教徒”，就好像这有什么特殊含义似的。但他们现在还被称为胡格诺派吗？不。好吧。不。所以那个场景，大屠杀的场景，因为非常像《权力的游戏》，极其惊心动魄且可怕。所以它确实让人体会到了整件事情是多么可怕、嗜血、毛骨悚然的野蛮。而且之后的事情，其余波在某种程度上更糟，那是成堆的赤裸尸体堆在推车上，简直太可怕了。我大约30年前看过那部电影，在你提起之前我几乎没怎么想过它，
it up and i have to say i mean maybe some listeners won't be surprised to hear this but all the nudity the intense intense violence. I thought it was absolutely brilliant. I really enjoyed it. Mind you, I like Game of Thrones. I saw it. I'd done it for A-level, so I was very disappointed. I felt that it was historically inaccurate. Oh, Tom.
我不得不说，也许有些听众听到这个不会感到惊讶，但所有的裸露镜头、极度强烈的暴力场面，我都觉得简直绝了。我真的很喜欢。不过话说回来，我喜欢《权力的游戏》。我当时看过了，我把它当作A-level（英国高中课程）的历史考纲内容看过的，所以我非常失望。我当时觉得它在历史上有失准确。哦，汤姆。
It absolutely ruined it for me. So I must go back and give it another go. I suspect you'll be very pleased with Muriel's third choice because I know what that is. So do I. It's a film that you love, Tom.
它彻底毁了我的观感。所以我得回去重新再看一遍。我猜你会对穆里尔的第三个选择非常高兴，因为我知道那是什么。我也是。那是你深爱的一部电影，汤姆。
It is. I think it's the single best historical film ever made. Wow. Well, yes, it's very strong. So this is Ridicule, which presumably was released here as ridicule yes ridicule yes and by patrice lecomte and that is again a 1990s movie so people will say i'm
确实如此。我认为这是有史以来拍得最好的单一历史电影。哇。好吧，是的，评价很高。这就是《荒诞无稽》（Ridicule），它在这里上映时大概叫作《嘲弄》吧？是的，《嘲弄》，由帕特里克·勒孔特（Patrice Leconte）执导，这也是一部90年代的电影，所以人们可能会说我在
favoring the 1990s but i've i've tried to be even-handed in terms of the kinds of films and the quality you know having constant quality so quality. So, Ridicule is brilliant. Ridicule is a sort of historical comedy of manners and drama set at court in Versailles. So, this is towards the end of the Ancien Régime and the reign of Louis XVI. Although actually, we barely see the king. We catch a glimpse of Marie Antoinette, but it's not about them. It's about the courtiers and what goes on in those circles at court. So the main character is a young nobleman from the provinces called Grégoire Ponce-Ludon de Malavoie, which I think is an outlandish name because he is from the back from the back
偏爱90年代，但我一直在努力在电影的类型和质量上保持公正，你知道，保持一贯的高水准。所以，《荒诞无稽》太棒了。这是一部以凡尔赛宫廷为背景的历史风俗喜剧兼剧情片。所以，这是在旧制度（Ancien Régime）末期和路易十六统治时期。尽管实际上，我们几乎看不到国王。我们瞥见了玛丽·安托瓦内特，但这不是关于他们的故事。这是关于朝臣们以及宫廷那些圈子里发生的事情。所以主角是一个来自外省的年轻贵族，名叫格雷古瓦尔·蓬斯-吕东·德·马拉沃（Grégoire Ponce-Ludon de Malavoie），我认为这是一个古怪的名字，因为他来自偏远
waters and he is um enlightened young nobleman who's also a scientist a budding scientist he comes from a so where his sort of thief is is a very insalubrious marshy region. And he wants to drain the swamp in order to lengthen the, you know, the longevity of his peasantry. So he rides to Versailles in essentially a single shot to see the king, to seek audience with the king
地区，他是一个开明的年轻贵族，同时也是一个科学家，一个崭露头角的科学家。他来自一个——他的封地是一个非常不健康的沼泽地区。他想要排干沼泽，以便延长，你知道的，他领地上的农民的寿命。所以他基本上骑着马一气呵成赶到凡尔赛去见国王，寻求国王的接见
and get some funding for his project. And when he gets to Versailles, he discovers, and it is explained to him, that you can't just see the king just like that. You have to catch his eye. And the way to catch the king's eye is by being a celebrated wit. So he has to make as many coruscating witticisms in the presence of the other courtiers compete with the other courtiers in this kind of jousts of wit.
并为他的项目拉赞助。当他到达凡尔赛时，他发现，并且有人向他解释，你不能就这么随便见到国王。你必须吸引他的注意。而吸引国王注意的方法，就是成为一个名闻遐迩的机智之士。所以他必须在其他朝臣面前说出尽可能尖刻犀利的俏皮话，与其他人在这场机智的交锋中一较高下。
Puns don't count, very importantly. You can't just... And it has to be... I think it's something... There's a French word which is persiflage. Persiflage is a sort of ongoing banter, often malicious and witty. And that's what he needs to access.
双关语不算数，这一点非常重要。你不能只是……而且这必须是——我想这是某种东西……法语里有一个词叫作 persiflage。Persiflage（揶揄调侃）是一种持续的玩笑斗嘴，通常带有恶作剧性质且机智。这正是他需要掌握的。
That's what we have on this podcast. They have a joke. I mean, it's a joke isn't it that that there is actually no translation between the english and the french words it's a joke that kind of you know the film always ends with that joke yes there's a great scene where one uh nobleman this is in a woman's salon somewhere in versailles one nobleman has just returned from england and someone says do they have wit there and he says no no not really they have they have something called humor and then he tries to explain what it is and it falls completely flat but actually the the last scene of the film has a lovely little trait d'esprit uttered by an Englishman, which is about, it's better to lose your hat than to lose your head. You know,
这就是我们在这一档播客中所做的。他们开了一个玩笑——我的意思是，这是一个笑话，对吧？英语和法语里其实没有对应的翻译。这是一个笑话，电影总是以这个笑话结束。是的，有一个很棒的场景，一个贵族——这是在凡尔赛某个女性的沙龙里——一个贵族刚从英国回来，有人问：“那里的人有机智吗？”他说：“不，不怎么有。他们有一种叫作幽默（humor）的东西。”然后他试图解释那是什么，结果完全冷场了。但实际上，电影的最后一个场景是由一个英国人说出的一句非常可爱的俏皮话，意思是，失去帽子总比失去脑袋好。你知道的，
to carry on doing L'illusion. I've been here a very long time. But it is a beautiful film. And again, I mean, as with La Reine Margaux, but differently, it sort of shatters the expectations you might have of a historical drama because it's very impolite. It's rude, you know, and at the same time, it's incredibly sophisticated. It's just a wonderful alliance of things. So I said, I think this is the best historical film ever made. And I think the reason I think that is that it makes drama out of a completely different way of understanding the world, the rituals of Versailles, the, as you say, these kind of
继续过着虚妄的生活。我在这个地方待了很久了。但这是一部美丽的电影。而且，与《玛戈王后》一样但方式不同，它粉碎了你对历史剧的固有期待，因为它非常不礼貌。它很粗鲁，你知道的，与此同时，它又极其精致。它简直是各种事物的奇妙结合。所以我说，我认为这是有史以来最好的历史电影。我认为原因在于，它将一种完全不同的世界观、凡尔赛的礼仪、如你所说的那种
duels of wit, that is something that only makes sense in that specific historical circumstance. And it's not about kind of importing our standards and imposing them on the past, as so many history films are and i i have i've watched it lots of times and i i think it is absolutely i think it's absolutely superb um and there there is one brilliant moment particularly brilliant moment there's an abbé who is a kind of voltairian um priest who uh is absolute master of wit and he gives a kind of brilliant sermon and the king applauds him and the whole court are in raptures. And then he says that I will demonstrate that God doesn't exist. And at that, suddenly you can hear a pin drop and he realizes he's gone too far.
机智的决斗，转化成了戏剧冲突，这只有在那种特定的历史环境下才说得通。它不是那种把我们的标准强加给过去的影片——就像那么多历史电影做的那样——我看了很多遍，我认为它绝对是，我认为它绝对棒极了。而且里面有一个极其精彩的时刻，特别精彩的时刻：有一个神甫，他是一个伏尔泰式的神父，绝对是机智的大师。他发表了一篇精彩绝伦的布道，国王为他鼓掌，整个宫廷都听得如痴如醉。然后他说：“我将证明上帝并不存在。”就在那时，你会突然听到一根针掉地上的声音，他意识到自己走得太远了。
And it's such a brilliant, brilliant moment. And, you know, as you said, it's also about the revolution because that sequence at the end where the exile is standing on the white cliffs of Dover with the Englishman, you know, he's gone into exile because of the revolution, but our hero is now, you know, citoyen, whatever he is. And has managed to drain the swamp. Drain the swamp. Well, your next film, Muriel, does feature the French Revolution, doesn't it?
这是一个多么精彩、多么绝妙的时刻。而且，正如你所说，它也关乎大革命。因为最后那个流亡者和英国人一起站在多佛白崖上的序列——你知道的，他因为大革命而流亡，但我们的主角现在是，你知道的，公民（citoyen），无论他现在是什么身份。并且成功排干了沼泽。排干了沼泽。好吧，你的下一部电影，穆里尔，确实涉及法国大革命，对吧？
And it also features that raggedy arse that I referred to at the very beginning in the introduction. So this is Boney. I mean, we couldn't do a podcast about French films without talking about Napoleon, I think. So this is a silent film, isn, we couldn't do a podcast about French films without talking about Napoleon, I think. So this is a silent film, isn't it? It is a silent film.
它还出现了我在开头引言中提到的那个衣衫褴褛的家伙。所以这就是“小邦”（Boney）。我的意思是，如果不谈论拿破仑，我们就无法制作一期关于法国电影的播客。所以这是一部默片，对吧？这是一部默片。
So it's the famous Napoleon by Abel Gance, which is I think 1923 or 27, perhaps, a bit later, 1920s film. It's an amazing project. Gance wanted to make a... It's very long. Again, I've chosen quite a few long films that people can pick and choose. This is five and a half hours long.
所以这是阿贝尔·冈斯（Abel Gance）著名的《拿破仑》，我想是1923年或1927年吧，稍微晚一点，20年代的电影。这是一个惊人的项目。冈斯想要制作一个——它非常长。再次说明，我选择了不少很长的电影，听众可以自行挑选观看。这部长达五个半小时。
And it's only a fragment because actually what Gance wanted to make was five times as much as that. He wanted to make a six-part epic, biopic, complete biopic, up to and including Saint Helena's. And of course, what he did because of the sort of artist that he was, is he blew his budget, his entire budget on the first.
而且它还只是一个残片，因为实际上冈斯想拍的规模是这个的五倍。他想要拍一部六部分的宏大史诗传记片，完整的传记片，一直拍到圣赫勒拿岛。当然，由于他是个那样的艺术家，他把预算、他整个的预算都花在了第一部分上。
We've all been there. And then ran out of money. But in a way, the fact that it's a fragment is part of the charm because it's a young Bonaparte. He hasn't been corrupted by hubris yet he's not become the emperor yet there is a sort of field of possibilities you know and more romantic idealism attached to the film because we don't get what came later and and Dominic you'll be very pleased to know that Nelson appears in it so um I've never I've watched the so I've seen kind of fragments, I think. Is that possible that the fragments exist? So I will tell you, I will tell you what happened because I met the person who I interviewed him, who put all these various fragments together again.
我们都经历过这种情况。然后就花光了钱。但从某种角度来看，它是残片反而成了魅力的一部分，因为这是一个年轻的波拿巴。他还未被狂妄自大所腐蚀，他还没有成为皇帝，那里充满了无限可能，你知道的，电影中附带着一种更具浪漫主义色彩的理想主义，因为我们还没看到后来发生的事。多米尼克，你会非常高兴地听到纳尔逊出现在里面。所以，我从来没看过去看这部——我只看过一些片段，我想。残片真实存在，这是可能的吗？所以我来告诉你，我来告诉你发生了什么，因为我采访过把这些不同残片重新拼凑在一起的那个人。
It was a man called Kevin Brownlow. Oh, he's a very well-known. As a very young man directed the film, It Happened Here about a Nazi occupation of Britain. And he was devoted to this and it became his great lifelong project to piece this film together. And it's still not entirely complete, but it's pretty much so. And I went and interviewed him, talked about the project, and saw it was screened in the, I think, in National Film Theatre. No, it was the Festival Hall, actually.
那个人叫凯文·布朗洛（Kevin Brownlow）。哦，他是个非常知名的——他很年轻时就导演了电影《英伦占领区》（It Happened Here），讲的是纳粹对英国的占领。他致力于此，这成了他毕生伟大的项目，将这部电影拼凑完整。它至今仍未完全完整，但也差不多了。我去采访了他，谈到了这个项目，并看到它在——我想是在国家电影剧院（National Film Theatre）放映的。不，其实是在皇家节日音乐厅（Festival Hall）。
And they had a full-blown orchestra. And the climax of it is that what has for most of the film is it's it's a single screen at the end suddenly you have three screens and it's it's like in Beethoven's Ninth when suddenly people start singing you know it's so unexpected and it's that was that was groundbreaking wasn't it when they they the triptych or whatever Muriel that was that was i'm presumably impossible to do in most cinemas i think so i think that you have to be in a specially equipped uh auditorium yes it was incredibly groundbreaking and triptych is the right word because there is a religious dimension to the whole enterprise um so what's exciting about the triptych is that lots of different things are happening simultaneously. You get a real sense of epic destiny, you know, unfolding before your very eyes.
他们有一个完整的管弦乐队。而高潮在于，电影大部分时间都是单屏幕的，到了结尾突然变成了三个屏幕，就像贝多芬第九交响曲里人们突然开始歌唱一样，你知道的，太出乎意料了。那就是——那是开创性的，对吧，当他们使用三联画或别的什么的时候，穆里尔，那在大多数电影院里大概是不可能做到的吧？我想是的，我认为你必须在一个特别配备的礼堂里才行。是的，这极具开创性，“三联画”这个词很贴切，因为整个宏大工程中都有宗教维度。
Why I say religious dimension is because there is, of course, a cult of Napoleon in France. There was while he was alive and then especially perhaps after he died, when he became a sort of martyr and secular saint really in the French imagination. Though again, I'm not sure that that's still with us. Martyr by the English again. Yes. And certainly, Gance very much channels that. So he saw the project as a sort of act of resurrection. And he talks about Napoleon as as a I think he says a sort of what is a radioactive heir to Christ you know his Napoleon on screen is going to fulfill Christ's republican mission you know Christ's famous republican mission
我之所以说有宗教维度，是因为在法国确实存在一种拿破仑崇拜。当他还活着的时候就存在，在他死后尤其是这样，他成为了法国人想象中的某种殉道者和世俗圣人。不过同样，我不太确定这种崇拜是否依然存在于我们身边。又被英国人塑造成殉道者了。是的。当然，冈斯非常强烈地传达了这一点。所以他将这个项目视为一种复活的行径。他把拿破仑描述为——我想他说的是某种对基督的放射性继承人，你知道的，他银幕上的拿破仑将要实现基督的共和使命，你知道的，基督著名的共和使命
he's going to complete it so there's a lot of you might say idolatry there on the part of goss and and that and actually the images brownlow made the most amazing act of reconstitution historical remembering of this film it's a beautiful evergreen movie it's worth watching in its entirety but even a fragment will give you a sense of the beauty of the images. It's absolutely beautiful. Didn't Stanley Kubrick want to make a film about Napoleon? He did. He was absolutely passionate about doing a new version of Napoleon. But he didn't get very far. Is that right, Muriel? I don't know how much you know about Kubrick's Napoleon.
他要将其完成。所以你可以说冈斯身上带有相当多的偶像崇拜。而且实际上，布朗洛制作的影像堪称对这部电影最惊人的历史重现与记忆复原。这是一部永恒的美丽电影，非常值得完整观看，哪怕只是看一个片段也能让你感受到那些画面的美感。它绝对美极了。斯坦利·库布里克不是一直想拍一部关于拿破仑的电影吗？他确实想拍。他对拍一部全新的《拿破仑》充满热情。但他没能推进太远。是这样吗，穆里尔？我不知道你对库布里克的《拿破仑》了解多少。
Yes, I think it's one of the great unrealised projects. Am I right in thinking it was going to be Jack Nicholson? I think so, yes. I think so. So you can imagine what that would have been like. Yeah. Okay. So that's Napoleon. And then what is number five?
是的，我认为这是那些未能实现的伟大电影项目之一。我没记错的话，主角原本定的是杰克·尼科尔森吗？我想是的，没错。我想是的。所以你可以想象那会是什么样子。是的。好吧。这就是拿破仑。那么第五部是什么？
I assume it's, well, it's, I know because you sent the list, but I'm very disappointed. So we're now moving into the 19th century, but I'm very disappointed to see that it's not Les Miserables. So Dominic mentioned Russell Crowe at the top. Yeah, I could have sung in Russell Crowe's beautiful voice. Partly that's it. I think for me, there is always a slight problem with suspension of disbelief when something is supposed to be a historical French drama. And then people walk in and say, hello, my name is Captain Gervais.
我猜它是——好吧，我知道，因为你发了清单，但我很失望。我们现在进入了19世纪，但我非常失望地看到它不是《悲惨世界》。多米尼克在开头提到了罗素·克劳。对，我本可以用罗素·克劳那美妙的嗓音唱出来。部分原因就在这里。我认为对我自己来说，当有些东西本应是法国历史剧时，总是存在一点审美代入的障碍。然后有人走进来，说：“你好，我是热韦少校（Captain Gervais）。”
And then you go, I'm not sure that I can really go with that. And then they start singing. I mean, that's even on bridges. And then there are angels in trees and it all. Yes. So this, my fifth choice is Les Enfants du Paradis, Children of Paradise, trees and it's all yes so this the my fifth choice is les enfants du paradis children of paradise i think it's called which is um a film by marcel carney and that was made under the german occupation and released at the time of the liberations it was made say in the mid 1940s and so again that is a part of the historical context, isn't it?
然后你会想：“我不确定我能不能接受这个。”然后他们开始唱歌。我的意思是，甚至还有桥梁。然后树上还有天使，这一切……是的。所以，我的第五个选择是《天堂的孩子》（Les Enfants du Paradis），我想它是这么叫的，是一部由马塞尔·卡内（Marcel Carné）执导的电影，它是在德国占领时期拍摄的，并在解放时期上映。它是大约在20世纪40年代中期拍的，所以这同样也是历史背景的一部分，对吧？
The difficulty of making the film, presumably. Yes, the difficulty of making the film under very difficult strictures from the Nazis and from Vichy, of course, as certain people not being allowed to work because they were Jewish or, you know, communists or whatever. So there were lots of... Most of the film was shot in the free zone,
拍摄这部电影的困难，可想而知。是的，在纳粹和维希政权极其严苛的限制下拍电影的困难，当然，某些人因为是犹太人或共产主义者等原因而不被允许工作。所以有很多……电影大部分是在自由区拍摄的，
in studios in Nice, where some extraordinary outdoor sets were built. So the action takes place... It's the Paris of Balzac, really. So it takes place mostly under Louis-Philippe, let's say, 1830s. And it's about that old Paris, the Paris before Hausmann's Paris,
在尼斯的工作室里，那里搭建了非常宏伟的户外布景。所以故事发生的背景是……这真的是巴尔扎克的巴黎。所以它主要发生在路易-菲利普统治时期，也就是1830年代。讲的是那个老巴黎，奥斯曼男爵改建巴黎之前的巴黎。
and centres around what was then called Boulevard du Crime, the crime boulevard, which was not called that because it was a very dangerous place, but because it was a place where a lot of theatres showed melodramas, gory, sensational melodramas, and also pantomimes. So the film is about the world of the theatre. The title refers, the children of paradise are the poorest people who can't afford expensive theatre seats and who can only afford the ones at the very top
围绕着当时被称为“犯罪大道”的地方展开，这条大道之所以叫这个名字，并不是因为它是一个非常危险的地方，而是因为这里有许多剧院上演着情节剧、血腥、耸人听闻的情节剧，还有滑稽哑剧。所以这部电影讲的是剧院世界。片名指的是天堂的孩子们，他们是最穷的人，买不起昂贵的剧院座位，只能买得起最顶层的座位
of the theatre. So it's like in English, the gods. The gods, exactly. And who are the people who bring atmosphere to any performance because they're the people who heckle and laugh and shout things and boo and hiss, all of that. So it's about the sort of interwoven destinies of a group of characters who are all in some ways connected to the theatre, really primarily, and centres around a woman called Garance, who is a performer and also just a pretty Parisian woman. So when we first see her,
剧院的。所以这就跟英语里的“神仙座位”一样。神仙座位，完全正确。而那些为任何演出带来气氛的人是谁呢，因为他们是那些起哄、大笑、大喊大叫、嘘声倒彩的人，所有这些。所以它讲述了一群角色的交织命运，他们都以某种方式与剧院联系在一起，实际上主要是围绕着一个叫加朗斯的女人展开，她是一个表演者，同时也是一个漂亮的巴黎女人。所以当我们第一次看到她时，
she's promenading on the Boulevard du Crime, which no longer exists. The Boulevard du Crime is a nickname that was given to Boulevard du Temple, which no longer exists as it was because du Crime is a nickname that was given to a boulevard du temple, which no longer exists as it was, because that place of promenade and theatres and popular entertainment is gone. It's been replaced by other boulevards and perspectives. Was that replaced by Haussmann?
她正在犯罪大道上散步，这条大道已经不复存在了。犯罪大道是给圣殿大道的昵称，它已经不再以原貌存在了，因为犯罪大道是给圣殿大道的昵称，它已经不再以原貌存在了，因为那个散步、剧院和大众娱乐的地方已经消失了。它被其他大道和视角所取代。那是被奥斯曼取代的吗？
So that was Haussmann knocked all that away? Yes, yes. So you can't visit it, but you can go back in the amazing time machine of Les Enfants du Paradis. It is the most extraordinary super production in terms of French cinema. I think that set alone, the Boulevard set, which contains Trompe-l'œil elements, cost 5 million francs, which at the time is absolutely pharaonic sum. And so this is during the Second World War and the occupation. So it must have been challenging to raise the money. And to what extent does the circumstance of the occupation provide context, if any have been difficult, but at the same time, filmmakers were encouraged under Vichy to make non-contemporary films to portray the past.
所以那是奥斯曼把这一切都拆掉了？是的，是的。所以你没法去参观，但你可以乘坐《天堂的孩子们》这部神奇的时间机器回到过去。就法国电影而言，这是最了不起的超级制作。我想光是布景，那个包含错视画元素的林荫大道布景，就花了500万法郎，在当时这是一笔天文数字。所以这是在二战和占领期间。因此筹集资金一定充满挑战。而占领时期的环境在多大程度上提供了背景，如果有的话一定很艰难，但与此同时，维希政府鼓励电影制作人拍摄非当代电影来描绘过去。
For obvious reasons. For obvious reasons, it was perceived to be safer. And also, possibly people wanted to escape into recreations of the past because the present was not a barrel of laughs. So there was demand for those kinds of films and something that would not have any political agenda attached to it was would also be supported where the circumstances of the occupation are perhaps perceptible is in the general tone of the film which is so marcel carney is one of the exponents of Realisme Poétique, poetic realism, which is a 1930s school of film in France. And what that means is a sort of
出于显而易见的原因。出于显而易见的原因，人们认为这样更安全。而且，可能人们也想逃避到对过去的重现中，因为现实一点也不好玩。所以当时对这类电影有需求，任何不带有政治议程的东西也会得到支持，而占领时期的环境也许在电影的整体基调中依稀可辨，马塞尔·卡尔内是诗意现实主义的代表人物之一，诗意现实主义是20世纪30年代法国的一个电影流派。这意味着一种
proto film noir. So it's often a very fatalistic, pessimistic, tragic stories, often love stories, not always, and centering on characters who are not upper class characters, but ordinary people, ordinary people and their joys and pains, and then often impossible love. So the film is permeated with this air of tragedy. It's about a mime, a famous real life mime called De Bureau, who in a way invented the art of mime, and a tragedian, an actor called Frédéric Lemaitre, who was one of the great figures of the French stage in the 19th century.
黑色电影的雏形。所以它通常是非常宿命论、悲观、悲 tragic 的故事，通常是爱情故事，但也不全是，而且中心人物不是上流社会人物，而是普通人，普通人及其欢乐与痛苦，然后往往是无法实现的的爱。所以整部电影弥漫着这种悲剧气氛。它讲的是一个哑剧演员，一个现实生活中的著名哑剧演员叫德比罗，他在某种程度上发明了哑剧艺术，还有一个悲剧演员，一个叫弗雷德里克·勒迈特演员，他是19世纪法国舞台上的伟大人物之一。
And then there are a couple of others. Lesner, the poet assassin, the darling of the surrealists, also features in the film. And they're all in love with this woman called Garance, who is also a performer. And it's about how everyone all in love with this woman called Garance, who is also a performer. It's about how everyone's in love with the wrong person, and in the end, happiness is completely unattainable. That's where perhaps there's a melancholy there that is to do with the circumstances. Just one other question on the wartime context, which is that this image of Paris, it's the Paris of La Boheme, the Paris of
然后还有另外几个人。列斯纳，这个超现实主义者的宠儿、诗人刺客，也在电影中出场。他们都爱上了这个名叫加朗斯的女人，她也是一个表演者。讲的是每个人都爱上了这个名叫加朗斯的女人，她也是一个表演者。讲的是每个人都爱错了人，最后幸福是根本无法得到的。也许这就是那种与环境有关的伤感所在。关于战时背景还有一个问题，就是巴黎的这个形象，它是波希米亚人的巴黎，是
the stage and of doomed love and of beautiful courtesans and all that kind of thing. I mean, that is a very popular foreign perspective on Parisian culture. Do you think that, was there any kind of awareness of that, that this was about reminding the world beyond France that, you know, La Belle Paris was still there, that she was still this city of great actors and prostitutes and courtesans and aristocrats and paup, and bohemians, that that was still going on, do you think? I think that's certainly true. I think it's very aware of the myth of Paris and of promoting and recreating
舞台、注定失败的爱情、美丽的交际花以及诸如此类事物的巴黎。我的意思是，那是外国人对巴黎文化非常普遍的一种看法。你觉得，当时是否有这样一种意识，即这是为了提醒法国以外的世界，你知道，美丽的巴黎依然存在，她依然是那个拥有伟大演员、妓女、交际花、贵族、穷人和波希米亚人的城市，这一切仍在继续，你觉得是这样吗？我想这肯定是真的。我认为它非常清楚巴黎的神话，并且在推广和重现
immersively that vanished, great old Paris of, as you say, culture, love, living on the edge, the underbelly of society, aristocratic salons, everything is in it. So in that sense, it's very Balzac and quite Dickensian also. It has everything. And the script was written by the poet Jacques Prévert, wasn't it? Does that suggest to us that film, is that a sign of film being regarded as one of the high arts in France in a way that perhaps it isn't in, well, certainly not in Britain, I suppose. I mean, obviously, great American writers have worked for Hollywood, kind of people like William Faulkner and so on. But Prévert writing the film was filmed from the very beginning, seen as something that, you know, very clever, cultivated sort of artistic people would work in? And does French cinema, do you think, does it run the whole spectrum still from the most populist to the most highbrow? Interesting question.
沉浸式地展现那个消失了的、伟大的老巴黎，正如你所说，这里有文化、爱情、游走在边缘的生活、社会的阴暗面、贵族沙龙，应有尽有。所以从这个意义上说，它非常巴尔扎克，也很狄更斯。它包罗万象。剧本是由诗人雅克·普莱维尔写的，对吧？这是否向我们表明，电影在法国被视为高级艺术之一，而在英国或许并非如此，当然在英国肯定不是，我想。当然，伟大的美国作家曾为好莱坞工作过，比如威廉·福克纳等等。但是普莱维尔写电影剧本，从一开始就被视为一种聪明、有修养的艺术人士会参与的工作吗？你认为法国电影是否仍然涵盖了从最通俗到最阳春白雪的整个光谱？这是一个有趣的问题。
Yes, Jacques Prévert is a poet in his own right. He was also a screenwriter and he worked with Carnet several times. So he wrote dialogue, beautiful, witty dialogue that the courtiers in Ridicule might have approved of because it's often very beautifully, beautifully crafted. And at the same time, direct, limpid, unpretententious i think that's the genius of it and perhaps that is um the french less obsessed with class i think than the british i mean i don't know we can argue about that but i would say french cinema is less obsessed with class than british cinema which is perhaps a slightly different thing but uh and that's partly, I think, because the dream is always to create something that is a beautiful product that can be enjoyed by the majority of people. There are exceptions, and then there will be an example towards the end.
是的，雅克·普莱维尔本身就是一位诗人。他也是一名编剧，曾多次与卡尔内合作。所以他写了对白，美丽而机智的对白，连《嘲讽》中的朝臣们可能都会赞赏，因为它通常写得非常优美、极其精致。与此同时，又直接、清澈、不做作，我认为这就是它的天才之处，也许这就是嗯法国人不像英国人那么执着于阶级，我觉得，我不知道我们可以争论这一点，但我会说法国电影不像英国电影那么执着于阶级，这或许是一件稍微不同的事情，但是，部分原因在于，我认为，梦想永远是创造出一种能够被大多数人欣赏的美丽产品。也有例外，而且到最后会有一个例子。
There are, of course, exceptions, and French cinema can also be hyper-pretentious and very, very sort of over-engineered. But the mainstream, high and low and middle brow is trying to give everyone the best. That's the idea. A bit like food, really. Same attitude towards food. Well, there is certainly nothing pretentious or over-engineered about this podcast or this episode. And I think we should take a break at this point because we're now halfway through your list, Muriel. And when we come back, let's go from six through to 10. So à bientôt. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works.
当然也有例外，法国电影也可能超级做作、非常非常过度设计。但主流，无论是阳春白雪、下里巴人还是中产阶级趣味，都在努力给每个人最好的。这就是理念。有点像食物，真的。对食物的态度也一样。好吧，这个播客或这一集绝对没有什么矫揉造作或过度设计的地方。我想我们现在应该休息一下了，因为你的名单我们已经讲了一半了，穆里尔。等我们回来，我们就从第六讲到第十讲。所以，à bientôt。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐滑铁卢》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论和一丝八卦花絮。在我们的问答环节，我们拉开娱乐业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。
We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. The Avenue, once again, everybody. We are charging through the history of France in tenor films with our guest Mireille Zagat, the film critic, who has given us five splendid films. I have to say, having listened to you on those five films, Mireille,
我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想享受无广告收听、额外单集以及提前购买现场门票的权益，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。大道，各位，又见面了。我们将与我们的嘉宾、影评人米雷耶·扎加特一起，用十部电影回顾法国电影史，她已经给我们介绍了五部精彩的电影。我必须说，听了你讲的那五部电影，米雷耶，
it makes me want to watch them, in the case of La Reine margot re-watch them uh immediately but you've got some great ones coming up haven't you because i can see the list and your next one is particularly interesting i think because of the controversy around it and because a lot of people probably don't even know it exists and so that is um, um, Jacques Hughes is a French title by Roman Polanski, but it has a British connection, doesn't it? It does because, um, it's an adaptation. So it's about the Dreyfus affair. Um,
这让我想立刻去看它们，如果是《玛戈王后》的话甚至想立刻重温。不过你接下来还有几部很棒的电影，对吧？因为我能看到名单，你的下一部特别有趣，我想是因为围绕它的争议，以及很多人可能甚至不知道它的存在，那就是，嗯，罗曼·波兰斯基导演的法国片名是《特雷茨》，但它与英国有联系，对吧？确实有，因为，嗯，这是一部改编作品。所以讲的是德雷福斯事件。嗯，
so we are now from the Paris of Balzac, we've moved to the Paris of Proust, uh, the late 19th century. The, the film of Proust, the late 19th century. The film is, the script is adapted from a novel by Robert Harris called, I think, An Officer and a Spy. And I had not known, actually, I recently found out that Harris wrote the novel as a result of a conversation with Polanski. And then they decided to make the film together and make the novel into a film. But they both shared an interest in the Dreyfus affair. They're friends.
所以我们现在从巴尔扎克的巴黎，移步到了普鲁斯特的巴黎，19世纪末。普鲁斯特的电影，19世纪末。这部电影，剧本改编自罗伯特·哈里斯的一部小说，我想书名叫《军官与间谍》。我其实并不知道，我最近才发现哈里斯写这部小说是因为与波兰斯的对话。然后他们决定一起拍这部电影，把小说拍成电影。但他们俩都对德雷福斯事件感兴趣。他们是朋友。
And so that's how the novel came to be. And then later the film. So the genius... So for people who don't know, because a lot of people won't, the Dreyfus affair, do you want to explain that? Well, are you happy explaining it? If I make any mistakes, you, the historian, can correct me. I'm sure you won't. So this is something that happened in, I think, 1894, thereabouts.
这部小说就是这样诞生的，后来的电影也是如此。所以天才之处在于……所以对于那些不知道的人来说，因为很多人都不知道，德雷福斯事件，你想解释一下吗？好吧，你愿意解释吗？如果我犯了任何错误，你这位历史学家可以纠正我。我确信你不会的。所以这是一件发生在，我想，1894年左右的事情。
An officer in the French artillery called Captain Alfred Dreyfus, who was French but from Alsace and also Jewish, crucially, was accused, well, found guilty, accused and then found guilty of treason, of specifically passing on military secrets to the Germans. And he was then expelled from the army. He was, there was a, so yes, I'll get onto that afterwards, but he was then sent to Devil's Island in French Guyana for lifelong imprisonment. A living death, wasn't it? A living death. And the film opens with a famous scene of his literal degradation in the courtyard of the École Militaire in Paris,
法国炮兵的一名军官，名叫阿尔弗雷德·德雷福斯上尉，他是法国人，但来自阿尔萨斯，而且至关重要的是，他还是犹太人，他被指控，嗯，被判有罪，被指控然后被判犯有叛国罪，具体来说是向德国人传递军事秘密。然后他被军队开除。他被，有一个，所以是的，我一会儿会讲到，但他随后被送往法属圭亚那的魔鬼岛进行终身监禁。这是一场活生生的噩梦，对吧？一场活生生的噩梦。电影以他在巴黎军校庭院里被公开羞辱的著名场景开场，
where all his epaulettes, the gilt buttons on his uniform, everything is torn from his uniform. And then the soldier who is doing all this to him breaks his sword on his knee, breaks it in half. And at that point, Dreyfus exclaims that he is innocent and that it's a terrible miscarriage of justice. Vive l'armée, vive la France, he says. The genius of the film, which is, of course, the genius of Harris's novel, is to tell the story centering not around Dreyfus himself, who is a tricky character because he was quite a chilly sort of cold fish, you know, he's not very charismatic, or centering around Émile Zola, the French writer who wrote the open letter to the president entitled Jacuzzi, which outed the whole story in newspapers but on another officer called
他制服上的所有肩章、制服上的镀金纽扣，全都被从制服上扯了下来。然后做这一切的士兵当场把他的宝剑在膝盖上折断，折成两半。就在那时，德雷福斯大声宣称他是无辜的，这是一场可怕的冤案。他说：“法国军队万岁，法兰西万岁。”这部电影的天才之处，当然也是哈里斯小说的天才之处，在于故事不以德雷福斯本人为中心，他是一个棘手的人物，因为他有点冷漠孤傲，你知道的，他不是很具有人格魅力，或者不以埃米尔·左拉为中心，这位法国作家曾写了一封致总统的公开信，题为《我控诉》，在报纸上揭露了整个事件，而是聚焦于另一位军官，
george picard who was dreyfus's commanding officer at the time when he was first convicted and who is then promoted as head of the secret service the french secret service and in the course of that of these new activities, discovers that actually Dreyfus was telling the truth, that he was innocent, that he's been framed, that proofs of his guilt have been fabricated and he sets about to set the record straight. And what's interesting is that this Picard character, who is played by Jean Dujardin, so Jean Dujardin is perhaps today the biggest male French star. He's very, you know, he's tall, dark and handsome
乔治·皮卡尔，他正是德雷福斯最初被定罪时德雷福斯的长官，随后他晋升为法国秘密情报局的局长。在这些新职务的履职过程中，皮卡尔发现德雷福斯其实说的是实话，他是无辜的，他是被陷害的，他有罪的证据是捏造的，于是他着手拨乱反正。有趣的是，这个皮卡尔角色由让·迪雅尔丹饰演，让·迪雅尔丹也许是当今法国最具号召力的男星。他很高大、皮肤黝黑、长相帅气，
and very debonair. But here he plays against type because he's playing what I would call un cello, so thoroughly unpleasant individual who is himself a staunch anti-Semite. And of course, perfectly mainstream opinions to have for a man of his class and background in the army at the time. But this is not a Hollywood scenario where he starts off perhaps
而且非常温文尔雅。但在这里他反其道而行之，饰演了一个我称之为 un cello 的角色，一个彻头彻尾令人讨厌的人，而他本人又是一个坚定的反犹太主义者。当然，对于当时军队中那个阶层和背景的人来说，这完全是主流观点。但这并不是那种好莱坞式的剧本，一开始他可能
a little bit anti-Semitic, but then he gets to know Dreyfus and they become best buddies and he warms to the plight of the Jews. Thank you, Alfred. Thank you for being there. It's not like that. What drives him is his love of the army and his sense of duty and so he wants to um exculpate dreyfus bring him back for another trial and also make sure that the actual culprit the man who was selling military information to the germans a major esterhazy is uh pursued instead. I haven't seen the film, but I have read Robert Harris's book. I think I read it in proof before it came out. And I remember it was one of those reading experiences that sort of stays with you because
有点反犹，但后来他开始了解德雷福斯，两人成了好基友，他开始对犹太人的苦难产生同情。谢谢你，阿尔弗雷德。谢谢你在那里。事情不是这样的。驱使他的是他对军队的热爱和他的责任感，所以他想要洗清德雷福斯的罪名，让他重新接受审判，并确保真正的罪魁祸首——那个向德国人出售军事信息的少校埃斯特哈齐——受到追究。我没看过这部电影，但我读过罗伯特·哈里斯的书。我想我是在它出版前的校对阶段读的。我记得那是一种挥之不去的阅读体验，因为
I started reading it, you know, at sort of six o'clock at night and was still reading it at two o'clock in the morning or something. Even though I knew the story, I think it's by farbert harris's best book and i was absolutely riveted but the tragedy is that the film hasn't had um the exposure that it should have done because of course roman polanski is a very controversial figure because of his own sort of sexual history and so on but is that that's presumably not the case in france muriel or? No, it's interesting because in terms of history in the making, France had its, is having really, perhaps, its Me Too moment with a slight lag after Le Monde Anglo-Saxon, as ever, we're always sort of chasing the, running after the train slightly. And the release of the film coincided with that.
我开始读的时候，你知道，大概是晚上六点钟，一直读到凌晨两点左右。尽管我知道这个故事，但我认为这是罗伯特·哈里斯最好的一本书，我完全被迷住了。但悲剧在于，这部电影没有得到它应有的曝光度，当然是因为罗曼·波兰斯基因为他自己的某种性史等原因是一个非常有争议的人物。但穆里尔，在法国情况大概不是这样的吧，或者说？不，这很有趣，因为就正在创造的历史而言，法国也有，或者说正在经历它的“我也是”（Me Too）时刻，比盎格鲁-萨克逊世界稍微滞后了一点，一如既往，我们总是有点在追赶那列火车。而电影的上映恰逢其时。
So I won't go into the Polanski affair, which is a separate thing, but yes, Polanski admitted to having had non-conceptual sex with an underage girl in the 70s. And he's still really a fugitive from American justice for that crime. He's been tried, but he hasn't been in prison. He jumped bail, didn't he? He jumped bail and he's never been back to the US. So he's now 88 years old, maybe Polanski,
所以我不会深入探讨波兰斯基事件，那是另一回事，但是的，波兰斯基承认在70年代与一名未成年女孩发生过非自愿性行为。对于这起罪行，他实际上仍然是美国司法的逃犯。他受过审判，但没有坐牢。他弃保潜逃了，对吧？他弃保潜逃了，再也没有回过美国。所以波兰斯基现在已经88岁了，也许
87 years old. And this is still hanging over his head like a sword of Damocles. And occasionally it's sort of wheeled out, you know, again. And this was a case in point, partly because the Dreyfus affair is the story of you know an innocent man being unjustly uh hounded by uh by the authorities by the media and so on it's so there was um disapproval and resistance in in France to the film being lionized at the Venice Festival for example and a lot of people I, people in the press said they would not promote the film, they would not talk about it. Planned interviews with some of the stars in the movie, Jean Dujardin, Louis Garrel, who plays Dreyfus, who's also a famous French actor, were cancelled. So there was certainly a reaction. This is all
87岁了。这件事依然像达摩克利斯之剑一样悬在他的头顶。而且偶尔还会被拿出来说事，你知道的。这就是一个典型的例子，部分原因在于德雷福斯事件讲的是一个无辜的人遭到当局、媒体等的不公正迫害的故事，所以法国对这部电影在威尼斯电影节上受到奉承感到不满和抵制，比如很多媒体人表示他们不会宣传这部电影，也不会谈论它。原本计划与电影中的一些明星进行的采访，包括让·迪雅尔丹、饰演德雷福斯的吉约姆·卡内（注：此处原文为 Louis Garrel 路易·加瑞尔，知名法国演员），都被取消了。所以确实有强烈的反应。这一切
happening in a wider context in France, where for the first time in my own living history, the penny is dropping in French society that it is not okay to pursue underage girls with sexual intent. Because actually, the Polanski affair, although it happened in America, in a French context, happened in a context where it was all perfectly acceptable and even applauded that young women nymphettes lolitas were fair game and that it is it was hilarious to pursue them capture them seduce them well also that's one aspect of french seduction which is at the darker end of the i mean there's also with polanski there's also uh sharon tate he was married to sharon tate wasn't he and and she obviously was very brutally murdered by um the manson family
发生在法国更广泛的背景下，在法国社会中，我有生以来第一次，人们开始幡然醒悟，意识到带着性目的去追求未成年女孩是不对的。因为事实上，波兰斯基事件虽然发生在美国，但在法国的背景下，它发生在一个完全可以接受、甚至受到赞赏的环境中，即年轻的少女、洛丽塔们是合法的猎物，追求她们、捕获她们、诱惑她们是一件非常滑稽的事。嗯，这也是法国诱惑的一个方面，属于比较阴暗的一面——我的意思是，对波兰斯基来说，还有莎朗·泰特，他曾与莎朗·泰特结婚，对吧，而她显然被曼森家族残忍地谋杀了，
the manson family so uh it's there is this kind of very dark background to it but um i haven't seen it i've like dominic i read the book and kind of read it in a single sitting so i love the book um but i feel quite inspired to go and see the film now i must say um just one quick question about drafus if i may um the drafus affair you would have thought was kind of closed until recently but i'm not right in thinking that there's say for example the um the sort of hard right candidate sort of gadfly eric zemmour who is himself jewish very odd unbelievably he said at the beginning of the recent french presidential campaign well maybe dreyfus was was guilty maybe it wasn't as simple as that maybe you know he wasn't framed
曼森家族——所以这背后有一种非常黑暗的背景。不过，嗯，我没看过，我像多米尼克一样读了这本书，而且是一气呵成读完的，所以我很喜欢这本书。但我现在真的很想去看这部电影，我必须得说。嗯，关于德雷福斯，我有一个简单的问题，如果可以的话——大家会以为德雷福斯事件直到最近才算是告一段落，但我是不是没想错，比如说，像极右翼候选人、爱管闲事的埃里克·泽穆尔，他自己也是犹太人，非常奇怪，令人难以置信的是，他在最近的法国总统竞选刚开始时说，也许德雷福斯是有罪的，也许事情没那么简单，也许，你知道，他并不是被冤枉的？
do many people in france think that muriel i should think not i think it's a very marginal niche opinion zemmour also thinks that the vichy regime was marvelous and did its best to save he also wants french jews he wants to annex northern italy doesn't he so he has a raft of controversial opinions he's he's an eccentric foreign policy yeah an eccentric figure yes yes i think you that is sort of lunatic French, I'd say. Okay. So, number seven. Number seven is La Grande Illusion, the Renoir film about the Great War, Grand Elysian, which was made in 1937. So it was made between the two wars, but it is a film that's looking back to Renoir's own experience in the war as a pilot. He was a pilot. And so it's about, it's very,
法国有很多人这么认为吗，穆里尔？我觉得不会吧，我认为这是一种非常边缘的小众观点。泽穆尔还认为维希政权棒极了，竭尽全力拯救了……他还想让法国犹太人……他想吞并意大利北部，对吧？所以他有一堆极具争议的观点。他是个古怪的外交政策……一个古怪的人物，是的，是的。我想你可以说那是法式的疯狂吧。好吧。那么，第七部。第七部是《大幻灭》，雷诺阿关于一战的电影，拍摄于1937年。所以它是两战之间拍摄的，但这部电影回顾了雷诺阿自己作为飞行员的参战经历。他曾是一名飞行员。所以它是关于——
it's perhaps the most famous of all my choices. It's the great humanist anti-war film about friendship. It's about French prisoners who escaped from German prisons during the First World War. And the thing about it is that they... So at the beginning, we have three characters, an aristocrat called de Bois-le-Dieu and an engineer, a working class man,
这也许是我所有选择中最著名的一个。这是一部关于友谊的伟大的、人道主义的反战电影。讲的是第一次世界大战期间，从德国监狱逃跑的法国囚犯。最关键的是，他们……所以在开头，我们有三个角色，一个名叫德博勒迪约的贵族，一个工程师，一个工人阶级出身的人，
who's played by Jean Gadbin, who's called Maréchal, and then a Jewish, rich bourgeois Jewish character called Rosenthal, played by Marcel Dalio. Marcel Dalio always played Jews or foreigners in the cinema of the 30s. That was his stock in trade. And Jean Gabin is perhaps the greatest French film star ever, bigger than Brigitte Bardot, bigger than anyone,
由让·加本饰演，名叫马雷夏尔，然后还有一个富有的犹太资产阶级角色罗森塔尔，由马塞尔·达里奥饰演。马塞尔·达里奥在30年代的电影中总是扮演犹太人或外国人。那是他的拿手好戏。而让·加本也许是法国有史以来最伟大的电影明星，比碧姬·芭铎更大牌，比任何人都大牌，
who worked all his life. Reincarnated as a dog in 10%. Exactly. In the series about the talent agency in Paris. Yes. One of the directors has a dog called Jean Gabin and that's very telling. So Gabin is the incarnation of the French working man and the kind of figure of authenticity. He's about real France, France profonde, and also a very glamorous figure in his own right because he, during the war, the Second World War, he did join the Free French in North Africa.
他一生都在拍戏。在《百分之十》中转世成了一只狗。没错。在关于巴黎经纪公司的系列剧里。是的。其中一位导演养了一只名叫让·加本的狗，这非常说明问题。所以加本是法国工人的化身，也是一种真实性的象征。他是关于真正的法国（France profonde），而且他本身也是一个非常迷人的明星，因为他在二战期间加入了北非的自由法国。
He won the Croix de Guerre. So, you know, he's an interesting, glamorous figure. So in the film, these prisoners who are a sort of ragtag, motley crew of people who have nothing in common will subsume their class differences, the racial differences between them and find, you know, friendship and then manage to escape the Germans by helping each other out. So the aristocratic character sacrifices himself for the other two men so that they can escape. And then they eventually make it into Switzerland. And in the meantime, there's also a love story between Jean Gabin, the French soldier character, and a young German war widow. So that's also an interesting element of the film.
他获得了英勇十字勋章。所以，你知道的，他是一个有趣且迷人的角色。所以在电影中，这些囚犯是一群乌合之众，他们没有任何共同点，但他们超越了阶级差异、种族差异，找到了友谊，然后通过互相帮助成功从德国人手中逃脱。于是贵族角色为了其他两个人而自我牺牲，让他们得以逃脱。最后他们终于成功进入了瑞士。与此同时，让·加本饰演的法国士兵角色与一个年轻的德国战争寡妇之间也有一段爱情故事。这也是电影中一个有趣的元素。
There are a couple of things interesting about the Germansans aren't they so there's his affair i saw this years ago his his his relationship with the widow but there's also your classic i mean something that we in britain specialize in in war films your classic noble no i mean literally noble sort of german flying ace sort of a gallant enemy you know very chivalrous and all that sort of thing um and that's quite striking given that this is what 1937 the clouds of war overhead did you just say the clouds of war overhead i did i'd like a tom you know 200 odd episodes and i think one of the first times i've dipped into i've dipped into my deathless prose to give us credit i think that's the first time we've dipped into my deathless prose. To give us credit, I think that's the first time we've ever used the phrase, the clouds of war.
关于德国人，有几点很有趣，不是吗？所以有他与那个寡妇的罗曼史——我多年前看过于此——他与寡妇的关系，但也有你们英国人在战争电影中很擅长的经典桥段，那种经典的、高尚的——我是说字面上的高尚——德国王牌飞行员，一种英勇的敌人，你知道的，非常具有骑士精神，诸如此类。嗯，考虑到这是在1937年，战争的阴云密布，这相当引人注目。你刚才是不是说“战争的阴云密布”？我是这么说的。我真想——你知道，两百多集了，我觉得这是我第一次把手伸进我那不朽的散文中……为了公平起见，我想这是我们第一次使用“战争的阴云密布”这个词。
Sorry, Doblin, go on. I'll start an episode with that. I'll start an episode with that term. We're only 20 years from the Great War itself. Obviously, the experience of the Great War for France, even more, far more seismic than it was for Britain. So was that controversial, would you say, to have sort of, you know, good Germans, as it were? Or by the 1930s, was that not an issue? I don't think it was an issue yet. When the film was re-released in 1946,
抱歉，多布林，继续。我要以这个词开始一集。我要以这个词开始一集。我们距离一战本身只有20年。显然，一战对法国的经历，比对英国的经历还要深远得多、更具震撼性。所以你认为，有这样的“好德国人”，是有争议的吗？还是说到了20世纪30年代，这已经不是问题了？我认为当时还不算是个问题。当这部电影于1946年重新上映时，
then there was a lot of resistance to the idea of the good Germans. But of course, the Germans portrayed in the film are not Nazis yet. They're from the past. So yes, there's an amazing scene where it is about class, where the gallant German officer who is played by a divine Austrian actor called Eric von Stroheim and the French aristocrat. So he's captured these French prisoners. And in front of the other two men, the two aristocrats, the German and the French, start to speak together in English, literally above the heads of the other two men. And they speak about horses and going to Mexims in Paris and, you know, in a way that signals the sort of fraternity of the upper
人们才对“好德国人”的观念产生了很大的抵触。但当然，电影中描绘的德国人还不是纳粹。他们来自过去。所以，是的，有一个非常精彩的场景，它关乎阶级，由一位上帝般的奥地利演员埃里克·冯·施特朗海姆饰演的英勇德国军官和法国贵族。所以他俘虏了这些法国囚犯。在另外两个人面前，德国贵族和法国贵族这两个贵族开始用英语交谈，简直是当着另外两个人的面。他们谈论马匹，谈论去巴黎的马克西姆餐厅，你知道的，这种方式暗示了上流社会的兄弟情谊，
classes that transcends frontiers and so do you know so so the figure of the good german also appears in um what is it the life and death of is it colonel blimp colonel death colonel yeah do you think you know was that was that an influence was um uh renoir's film an influence on that because that came out actually came out in the war, didn't it? I think that was because Churchill was suspicious of that, of the portrayal of the good German in that. But rather similar character. Rather similar character.
这种情谊超越了国界，你知道，所以……所以好德国人的形象也出现在……那是叫什么来着？《老奇士》（The Life and Death of Colonel Blimp）吗？布林上校，上校，死去的上校，对。你觉得，你知道，那是受其影响吗？雷诺阿的电影对它有影响吗？因为那部电影实际上是在战争期间上映的，对吧？我想那是因为丘吉尔对其中对好德国人的刻画持怀疑态度。但这是一个非常相似的角色。非常相似的角色。
What's his name? Von Kochdorf or something. Theo von Koch something. Wonderful. Played by Anton Wilbrook, another divine Austrian actor. So Colonel Blimp, it's about a kind of stereotypical British officer who becomes friends with this German officer, and it's his story through the war and then after it,
他叫什么名字？冯·科赫多夫还是什么的。泰奥·冯·科赫某某。太棒了。由安东·沃尔布鲁克饰演，另一位上帝般的奥地利演员。所以《布林上校》讲的是一个典型的英国军官，他与这个德国军官成为了朋友，讲述了他在战争期间及战后的故事，
up to the Second World War. But it's an archetype that runs through the way that the British, in particular, I think, think about the World Wars. There were always these sort of Klaus von stauffenberg yeah figures you know these noble adversaries with monocles or something um who know you know who who who who might as well have been to a public school and they know how to ride a horse and they yeah and they would scholars tom to pick up a theme that many of our listeners were familiar with, they would absolutely have worn the right shoes.
一直到第二次世界大战。但这是一个贯穿英国人思考世界大战方式的原型。总是有这些克劳斯·冯·施陶芬贝格式的角色，你知道，这些戴着单片眼镜或什么的崇高对手，他们知道，你知道，他们甚至可能上过公学，他们知道怎么骑马，而且，是的，而且他们会是学者，汤姆——借用一个我们的许多听众都会熟悉的梗——他们绝对会穿对鞋子。
They absolutely would. Well, I mean, we talked about Robert Harris. That's exactly that character features in the recent one about the Munich conference. Yes. Yes, that's right. So anyway, but we're... He loves a good German.
他们绝对会。好吧，我的意思是，我们谈到了罗伯特·哈里斯。这正是最近那部关于慕尼黑会议的电影中的那个角色。是的。是的，没错。所以无论如何，但我们……他就是喜欢好德国人。
We're now spiraling off into Britain, for which I apologize. So that is La Grande Illusion. And number eight. Number eight is also a film, well, it's a film that was made under the occupation, like Les Enfants du Paradis, but it's a very different film. So this is called Le Corbeau, The Raven. And it's a film by someone called Clouseau, but not that Clouseau. I know, Dominic's ears pricking up there. I did once write about this Clouseau, the director who spelled Z-O-T
我们现在偏题偏到英国去了，对此我深表歉意。这就是《大幻灭》。第八部。第八部也是一部电影，好吧，它是一部在占领时期拍摄的电影，就像《天堂的孩子们》一样，但这是一部非常不同的电影。这部电影叫《乌鸦》（Le Corbeau）。这是个叫克鲁佐的人拍的，但不是那个Inspector Clouseau（侦探克鲁佐）。我懂，多米尼克的耳朵立刻竖起来了。我曾经为《泰晤士报文学增刊》写过一篇关于这个克鲁佐的文章，那个导演的名字拼写是 Z-O-T。
for the Times Literary Supplement. And I spelled his name as in the Inspector Clouseau. And there was a letter Oh no! pulling me up which I should really frame and put on my wall to remind me of not making such silly mistakes. So Henri-Georges Henri-Georges Clouseau
而我把他的名字拼成了 Inspector Clouseau 的那个 Clouseau。结果收到了一封信——哦不！——把我纠正了一通，我真该把它裱起来挂在墙上，提醒自己不要犯这么蠢的错误。所以亨利-乔治·亨利-乔治·克鲁佐，
Z-O-T is a wonderful French filmmaker of the 30s, 40s, 50s and Le Corbeau is a film that was made within a German studio called, I think, Universal or something like that during the war in 1943. And it is about, it's a contemporary story.
Z-O-T 是30、40、50年代一位杰出的法国电影制作人，《乌鸦》是他在二战期间1943年在一个名为“环球”或类似名字的德国制片厂内拍摄的电影。它讲的是一个当代的故事。
So it's set in a contemporary setting, although it is careful to say in the opening title, a small town here or elsewhere. So it's not too specific about being set in France even. But the setup is a small town, a big village, where soon after the arrival of a new doctor called Dr. Germain, who is played by the same actor as the aristocrat in La Grande Illusion, Pierre Freinet, people in the town begin to receive horrible poison pen letters. So corbeau in French means raven, but it's also a word for blackmailer. And these letters threaten to reveal deep held secrets like
所以它的背景设定在一个当代环境中，尽管它在开场字幕中小心翼翼地注明了“此地或别处的一个小镇”。所以它甚至没有具体说明故事发生在法国。但故事的设定是一个小镇，一个大村庄，就在新来的医生日耳曼医生到达后不久——由《大幻灭》中饰演贵族的同一个演员皮埃尔·弗雷内饰演——镇上的人们开始收到可怕的匿名恶毒信件。“Corbeau”在法语中是乌鸦的意思，但它也是勒索者的代名词。这些信件威胁要揭露深藏的秘密，比如
illegitimacy, abortion, adultery, you know, all kinds of terrible things that people don't want others to know about. But Corbeau disseminates these letters everywhere. And this starts a kind of collective hysteria, really. It's based on a real case, on a real life case, which didn't happen at that time, but about 20 years previously in Tulle, I think in France, there was an epidemic of poison pen letters. So that's what inspired Clouseau. So in aulle, I think in France, there was an epidemic of poison pen letters. So that's what inspired Clouseau. So in a way, it's a kind of Miss Marple set up to begin with, because it's a small town. The moving finger. The moving finger. So there's, you know, there's the postmaster, there's the headmaster of the school, there's the nurse who works at the hospital, all these characters are there. And there's the presence of evil, the very real presence of evil,
私生子、堕胎、通奸，你知道的，各种人们不想让别人知道的糟糕事情。但“乌鸦”把这些信件到处散播。这引发了一种集体的歇斯底里，真的。它是基于一个真实的案件，一个真实生活中的案件，不是在那个时期发生的，而是在大约20年前的法国蒂勒，那里曾爆发过匿名恐吓信的流行潮。这就是克鲁佐的灵感来源。所以，在蒂勒，法国，我记得曾爆发过匿名恐吓信的流行潮。这就是克鲁佐的灵感来源。所以从某种程度上说，一开始它有点像马普尔小姐的设定，因为这是一个小镇。寓言之手（The Moving finger）。所以，你知道，有邮政局长，有学校校长，有在医院工作的护士，所有这些角色都在那里。还有邪恶的存在，一种非常真实的邪恶存在，
of this unseen, deranged personality who is poisoning the minds of the town. But Muriel, presumably, I mean, lurking at the back of this is the fact that there are informers. Yeah, it must be an occupation film. I mean, it's so obvious, isn't it? So how did it get past the census? Because presumably this is about people being denounced for being Jewish or…? It is. So the word we're looking for here is délation, which is a word that is almost exclusively associated with the occupation in France. And that means informing
来自这个看不见的、精神错乱的人格，正在毒害这个小镇的心灵。但穆里尔，我想，潜藏在这背后的事实是，这里有告密者。是的，这一定是一部占领时期的电影。我的意思是，太明显了，不是吗？那么它是如何通过审查的呢？因为这大概是关于人们因为是犹太人而被举报的，还是……？是的。所以我们在这里要找的词是 délation（告密），这个词几乎专门与法国的占领时期联系在一起。这意味着告密
on people because that was really the national sport during the occupation, encouraged both by the Germans and by the Vichy regime to encourage people to inform on their neighbors. Is there a communist hiding somewhere? Are there people harboring Jews? And people used to write anonymous letters
陷害他人，因为那是占领时期真正的国民运动，德国人和维希政权都鼓励人们去举报邻居。有没有共产党人藏在某个地方？有没有人藏匿犹太人？人们过去常常写匿名信
denouncing their neighbors, sometimes with a view to appropriating their shops or their house or their business or whatever. So it's a thoroughly unpleasant form of collaboration. And the film is a sort of metaphor of that. It doesn't describe that behavior directly because there's no political context. There's no gestapo. There's no sign of an occupying force. But that's because all that unpleasantness has been internalized.
痛斥他们的邻居，有时是为了霸占他们的店铺、房子、生意或别的什么。所以这是彻底令人不齿的合作形式。这部电影就是这种行为的一种隐喻。它没有直接描述这种行为，因为没有政治背景。没有盖世太保。没有占领军的迹象。但那是因为所有这些令人不快的东西都已经内化了。
So the surveillance is happening within the community and the atmosphere of paranoia, suspicion. The very fallen world that he describes is the world of the occupation, but it's not said directly. That's how he did it. I was about to say, there's a twist, though, isn't there? Because when you sent us the list and Le Corbeau was on it and I looked it up. I thought how amazing that this film came out in 1943. But so, so it's obviously about the informers and so on, but how closely it anticipates what happens after the liberation when people,
所以监视发生在社区内部，充满了偏执和怀疑的气氛。他所描述的那个极度堕落的世界就是占领时期的世界，但并没有直接说出来。这就是他的拍法。我正要说，不过有个反转，对吧？因为当你把名单发给我们，《乌鸦》在上面时，我查了一下。我觉得这部电影在1943年上映太神奇了。所以，所以它显然是关于告密者等等的，但它是多么准确地预示了解放后发生的事情，当时人们，
when women are having their heads forcibly shorn and people are informing on them for help for collaborating. So, so then there's another, yeah, exactly. Oh, you, you gave that German, you know German lunch, you slept with that German guy.
当女人们的头发被强行剃光，人们举报她们通敌。所以，然后又有一个，是的，正好。哦，你，你给了那个德国人，你知道的，德国午餐，你跟那个德国家伙睡了。
And then the sort of, again, it's the same story, but from a completely opposite angle. Exactly right. So it flips. The thing about women, just a quick word about women in the film that is so fascinating, is that there's a bad girl character, classic bad girl, femme fatale, amazing, played by an actress called Ginette Leclerc, who's sort of sex on legs,
然后这种，同样，还是那个故事，但从完全相反的角度切入。完全正确。所以它来了个反转。关于电影中的女性，简单说一句，非常吸引人的是，里面有一个坏女孩的角色，典型的坏女孩，蛇蝎美人，太棒了，由一个叫吉内特·勒克莱尔的女演员饰演，真的是性感尤物。
really. And she is portrayed sympathetically, whereas there's another female character who is a sort of walking poster girl for the Vichy regime, you know, the ideal of Vichy womanhood, who turns out to be a complete psychopath. So that's quite daring. And Vichy did not like that. And then, as Dominique mentioned, then later on, after the liberation, the disapproval against the film was of a different hue. It was no longer the Vichy authorities thinking that it was an immoral film that attacked family values, that catholicism all of that it was uh the resistance forces the the free french thinking that it was a demoralizing film and in itself
而且对她的刻画是富有同情心的，而另一个女性角色则是维希政权的某种行走的海报女孩，你知道的，维希理想女性的典范，结果却是个彻头彻尾的精神病患者。所以这很大胆。维希政府不喜欢这样。然后，正如多米尼克所提到的，后来在解放后，对这部电影的反对则是另一种调子。不再是维希当局认为这是一部攻击家庭价值观、天主教等一切的不道德电影，而是抵抗力量、自由法国认为这是一部令人士气低落的电影，本身
an act of collaboration because it portrayed france in a terrible um that is endless endless okay okay so we've got two to go um this is so i've now got eight films i'm very keen to watch this evening um two more so this one this one you were about to announce i watched last night ah it's fun isn't it it's it's tremendous it was not at all what I was expecting good good good um what were you expecting uh I I was expecting well so so it's La Grande Vendée which I think means the kind of the big stroll the big kind of perambulation um and I just read a very cursory account on the uh I brought it up on Amazon and they said three british pilots get shot down uh and it's about trying to get them back to england and so i was expecting a war film which it is a
就是一种通敌行为，因为它把法国描绘成了一个可怕的……没完没了，好吧，好吧——所以我们还有两部要讲——这个，我手里现在有八部电影，我今晚非常想看——还有两部，这部，你刚要宣布的那部我昨晚刚看。啊，很有趣，对吧？太棒了。完全出乎我的意料。很好，很好，嗯，你当时期待什么？嗯，我当时期待——好吧，所以它是《大逃亡》（La Grande Vadrouille），我想意思是那种长途漫步，大型漫步之类的——我刚刚在亚马逊上读了一个非常粗略的介绍，上面说三名英国飞行员被击落了，
war film but it's a war film in the way that well uh you know asterix is about the roman occupation of gaul yeah in that respect to cluso is about crime in the mean streets of Paris. Nobody dies, and there is absolutely no threat that anyone's going to die in it. And people in Britain may well have watched or heard of Alo Elo, which is, again, set against the occupation. Again, it deals massively in national stereotypes. And although you have the backdrop of the Wehrmacht and the Gestapo kind of lurking, you know, even they are kind of lovable clowns. So this was made, what, 1960s, wasn't it? I mean, it's a very 1960s. And all I will say for British is that the chief British pilot
讲的是如何把他们送回英国，所以我期待一部战争电影——它确实是一部战争电影，但它的战争方式就像……你知道的，阿斯特利克斯（Astérix）是关于罗马占领高卢的，对吧，在这方面，克鲁佐是关于巴黎平均街道上的犯罪的。没有人死，也绝对没有任何人会死的威胁。英国人可能看过或听说过《Allo 'Allo!》，它同样以占领为背景。同样，它大量运用了国家刻板印象。尽管你有德意志国防军和盖世太保作为背景潜伏着，你知道的，甚至连他们也像是可爱的丑角。所以这是在什么时候拍的，60年代，对吧？我的意思是，这是一部非常60年代风格的片子。而我只想为英国人说的一点是，英国飞行员的长官……
is played by Terry Thomas, which tells you everything you need to know about how the British are portrayed. So the director of this film, which was made in 1966, Gerard Houry, absolutely wanted Terry Thomas. I say, what a shower! All that kind of stuff. You're very good. You make a very good Terry Thomas. He wanted him for that, for his voice, but also for his moust for that for his voice but also for his mustache and for his guppy teeth well because the start he he gets he drops into the zoo doesn't he kind of drops into the penguin enclosure and his mustache is very bedraggled and the zookeeper rescues him and kind of signals go go and shave your mustache off immediately because you could not look more British, couldn't look more like an RAF pilot. So the story is broadly that these English parachutists land in various parts of Paris because their plane is shot down by the Germans. And they are rescued by this very unlikely pairing of complete no-hope Frenchmen played by two of the greatest comic actors in France,
由特里·托马斯（Terry Thomas）饰演，这说明了英国人是如何被刻画的。所以这部电影的导演，于1966年拍摄的热拉尔·乌里（Gerard Houry），绝对想要特里·托马斯。我说，真是一群废物！诸如此类的话。你演得真好。你把特里·托马斯演得真好。他找他是为了这个，为了他的声音，但也为了他的小胡子，呃，为了他的声音，但也为了他的小胡子和他的龅牙，因为开头他，他落入了动物园，不是吗？有点掉进了企鹅馆，他的胡子非常凌乱，动物园管理员救了他，并示意快，快把你的胡子刮掉，立刻，因为你看上去不能再英国人了，看上去不能再像一个英国皇家空军飞行员了。所以故事的大致内容是，这些英国伞兵降落在巴黎的各个地方，因为他们的飞机被德国人击落了。他们被两个完全不着调的法国倒霉蛋救了，这两个人由法国最伟大的两位喜剧演员扮演，
Bourville, and this is in the days where people had a one-name stage name, and Louis de Funès, who's perhaps the greatest comic actor France has ever known and is still utterly revered. So they play completely diametrically opposite types. One is a very easygoing painter, decorator, naive sort of childlike man, incredibly kind. And the de Funès character is a very choleric, as is always the case with his characters, conductor.
布尔维尔（Bourville），这是人们还用单名艺名的年代，还有路易·德·菲耐斯（Louis de Funès），他或许是法国有史以来最伟大的喜剧演员，至今仍备受尊崇。所以他们扮演的角色截然相反。一个是随和的画家、装饰工，天真烂漫的孩子气男人，极其善良。而德·菲耐斯扮演的角色是一个非常暴躁的乐队指挥，他的角色一贯如此。
With an extraordinary wig. With an extraordinary wig, which he has to. So again, they need to, they become embroiled with the English. And so they're not really very willing resistance. They are, you know, they're not ideological resistance. They are sort of embroiled in the whole thing. And they end up agreeing to help the British get to the free zone while on the run from the Germans. But as you said, the Germans in the film represent a very mild peril indeed, because although they're shooting
戴着一顶夸张的假发。戴着一顶夸张的假发，他不得不这样。所以同样地，他们需要，他们与英国人纠缠在了一起。所以他们并不是真的非常情愿地参加抵抗运动。他们，你知道的，他们不是意识形态上的抵抗战士。他们只是被卷入了整件事情中。最后，在躲避德国人的同时，他们同意帮助英国人到达自由区。但正如你所说，片中的德国人实际上只构成了非常轻微的危险，因为尽管他们有时会开枪，
sometimes, they don't appear to hit any target. It's almost as if they're made of cardboard. If you push them over, they fall over and they are hilariously obtuse and stupid and easy to bamboozle. As are the British, to a degree as well. Yes. So here the French are, these are ordinary Frenchmen. The comedy comes from their opposing temperaments. So there's a scene where De Funès, the sort of upper class character, tricks the other man into carrying him on his shoulders, you know, like a horse.
但他们似乎击不中任何目标。简直就像是用纸板做的一样。如果你推他们一下，他们就会倒下，而且他们滑稽地愚笨、迟钝，很容易被忽悠。英国人也一样，在某种程度上。是的。所以法国普通人就是这样。喜剧效果来自于他们对立的性格。所以有一个场景是，德·菲耐斯这个有点上流阶层的人物，忽悠另一个人用肩膀背着他，你知道的，就像骑马一样。
And he says, you give me a ride and I'll give you a ride later because his shoes hurt him, his feet are hurting. So that's the kind of class warfare you experience. But also they end up in all kinds of comedy of errors situations with the Germans. There's a hilarious scene where they walk into an inn. For some reason, they're wearing purloined German uniforms and they don't make very convincing Nazis and then they walk into this dark room at the inn the lights are turned on and there's a huge birthday party given for a Nazi officer so the room is full of Nazis
他说，你驮我一程，等下我也驮你一程，因为他的鞋磨脚，他的脚很疼。所以这就是你所经历的阶级斗争。但除此之外，他们还与德国人陷入了各种乌龙百出的情境中。有一个搞笑的场景是他们走进了一家客栈。出于某种原因，他们穿着顺手牵羊来的德国军装，而且他们看上去一点也不像是令人信服的纳粹，接着他们走进客栈的这个黑漆漆的房间，灯一亮，里面正在为一名纳粹军官举办一场盛大的生日派对，所以房间里挤满了纳粹，
in full regalia and they have to somehow blend in They all kind of sit down and go jumping around the room on their chairs, don't they? Which is a very famous scene Yes, so it's a relief, that film, after all the darkness of the occupation jumping around the room on their chairs, which is a very famous scene. Yes. So it's a relief, that film, after all the darkness of the occupation.
穿着全套制服，他们不得不设法融入其中。他们全都坐下来，在椅子上绕着房间跳来跳去，不是吗？这是一个非常著名的场景。是的，所以这部电影在经历了占领时期的所有黑暗之后，真是一种解脱，在椅子上绕着房间跳来跳去，这是一个非常著名的场景。是的，所以这部电影在经历了占领时期的所有黑暗之后，真是一种解脱。
And it's about healing with humour. Yeah. But I wondered, as a kind of British viewer, what it actually reminded me of was Asterix in Britain. Quite similar, where it's the French and the British kind of teaming up and the Romans are a bit like the Nazis. That's why I kind of alluded to it. But I always thought that there was something in that about the attitude of the French, the kind of mingled respect and resentment of the British that they were in a position to carry on
而且它是关于用幽默来治愈。是的。但我想知道，作为一个英国观众，它实际上让我想到了《高卢英雄历险记：英国行》（Asterix in Britain）。非常相似，法国人和英国人联合起来，罗马人有点像纳粹。这就是我为什么会暗指它的原因。但我一直认为，这里面体现了法国人的某种态度，一种对英国人的混合着尊重与怨恨的态度，因为当法国不得不投降时，英国人却有能力继续战斗。
fighting when France had to surrender. Do you think there's any element of that in this film? Yes, I'm sure there is. And I think there is in the French psyche too, actually, which explains also reactions to Brexit, for example, because this is a very broad brush statement, but it is a very different way to be as a nation to have won the war. The British won the war with the Americans, but nevertheless, they won the war. The French kind of won the war, but actually were first invaded, had years of a fascist-style regime where people collaborated actively with the enemy, and have to feel some gratitude to the American and the British,
你认为这部电影里有这种成分吗？是的，我确信有。而且我认为法国人的集体潜意识中也有，实际上，这也解释了例如对英国脱欧的反应，因为这是一个非常粗线条的说法，但作为一个赢得了战争的国家，其生存方式是截然不同的。英国人与美国人一同赢得了战争，但无论如何，他们赢得了战争。法国人某种程度上也赢得了战争，但实际上他们首先遭到了侵略，经历了多年的法西斯风格政权，许多人积极与敌人合作，并且不得不对美国人和英国人抱有一种感恩，
gratitude that is sort of never-ending. And gratitude is not always a very easy emotion. It really makes you hate the people that you feel grateful for. Well, de Gaulle is the classier sample of this, right? I mean, de Gaulle is the living embodiment of that sort of... He clearly at some level does feel gratitude, but also he feels an enormous sense of annoyance and resentment that he thinks through no fault of its own france was put in i think i think you know having watched that film yesterday i think there
一种似乎永远也报答不完的感恩。而感恩往往并不是一种轻松的情绪。它真的会让你讨厌那些你感到感激的人。嗯，戴高乐就是这方面的典型代表，对吧？我的意思是，戴高乐就是那种情绪的活生生的化身……他在某种程度上显然确实感到感激，但他也感到一种巨大的恼怒和怨恨，他认为法国并不是因为自身的过错才陷入这种境地。我想，我想你知道的，昨天看完那部电影后，我认为拍一部关于戴高乐的精彩喜剧是大有可为的，
would be scope for a brilliant comedy about to go um i mean he's not normally thought of as a but it would be could you not argue tom that at some level the inspector cluso forms are precisely that well i mean because cluso's sense of dignity right yeah i mean i know this is ludicrous to be mentioning cluso but his sense of dignity he really believes in france by the way inspector cluso and he believes in his job at the sure day and he believes in all that and there is a sort of stereotype in anglo-saxon culture of the, I'm going to say Anglo-Saxon, obviously I mean Anglo-American,
我的意思是，他通常不被认为是一个，但难道你不能说，汤姆，在某种程度上，彼得·塞勒斯的《粉红豹》里克卢梭探长系列电影恰恰就是那个吗？嗯，我的意思是，因为克卢梭的尊严感，对吧？是的，我知道提到克卢梭可能很荒谬，但他的尊严感，克卢梭探长他真的对法国深信不疑，顺便说一句，他相信他在法国国家安全局的工作，他相信这一切。在盎格鲁-撒克逊文化中存在着这样一种刻板印象，我要说盎格鲁-撒克逊，我显然是指盎格鲁-美国，
of the Frenchman who believes himself to be the soul of dignity, but to British eyes looks faintly ridiculous. But that's the brilliant thing about this, with the maestro who is constantly insisting on his dignity and his wig is constantly flying off and he's constantly having to wear the wrong shoes. It's wonderfully great. Very much a theme of this podcast. I cannot recommend Louis de Funès' movies highly enough because there's something so paroxysmic about all his performances. And I remember recently watching another film with him in it and thinking, I wonder how he died and he died of a heart attack. And I remember recently watching another film with him in it and thinking,
即法国人自认为是尊严的化身，但在英国人看来却显得有些滑稽可笑。但这就是这部电影的精彩之处，那个大师不断地坚持自己的尊严，而他的假发却总是飞掉，他总是不得不穿错鞋子。真是太棒了。这也是本播客的一个核心主题。我极力推荐路易·德·菲耐斯的电影，因为他的所有表演都有一种极度的爆发力。我记得最近看他的另一部电影时还在想，不知道他是怎么去世的，结果他是死于心脏病发作。我记得最近看他的另一部电影时还在想，
I wonder how he died and he died of a heart attack. And actually that's no surprise because I think he was always performing absolutely at full capacity. Yes. It's extraordinary. Yeah. Okay. Well, that's,
不知道他是怎么去世的，结果他是死于心脏病发作。其实这并不奇怪，因为我觉得他表演时总是竭尽全力、毫无保留。是的。太非凡了。是的。好吧，那是，
I love that film and I don't think I would ever have watched it if it hadn't been on this list. So I can't thank you enough. It was, it was fantastic. Okay. So our final, our final film
我很喜欢那部电影，如果不是在这个片单上，我想我永远也不会看它。所以我怎么感谢你都不为过。它真的很棒。好了。那么我们最后一部，我们最后的电影，
uh it's not such a barrel of laughs by jean-luc godard meeting up with dostoevsky and well it's not a comic it's not a comedy is it so this was made very soon after la grande vedouille it released a year later in 67, crucially. So the year before the Soissons-Ritard do their stuff. But many people say there's something prophetic about this film. So this film by Jean-Luc Godard, who, yes, is a very serious experimental filmmaker.
呃，让-吕克·戈达尔（Jean-Luc Godard）与陀思妥耶夫斯基的相遇，可没那么让人捧腹大笑。好吧，它不是一部喜剧，它不是喜剧，对吧？所以这部电影是在《虎口脱险》（La Grande Vadrouille）之后不久制作的，紧接着在一年后的1967年上映，至关重要的一点。也就是索邦大学学生暴动的前一年。但许多人说这部电影有一种预言性。所以让-吕克·戈达尔的这部电影，是的，他是一位非常严肃的实验电影制作人。
He is technically Swiss, but I think I can claim him because he works in France mostly and this film was made in paris for the french cast so we're not going to quibble about the swiss and the french here um it's a sort of um premonition of may 68 and and it's rooted in reality in the sense that so it's about it's about les grandes vacances it's summer and a group of French students, bourgeois students for the main part, hold up in a very bourgeois apartment in Paris, and they form a Maoist commune there.
他严格来说是瑞士人，但我想我可以把算作法国人，因为他主要在法国工作，这部电影也是在巴黎为法国演员制作的，所以我们在这里就不去纠结瑞士人和法国人了，呃，这有点像是，呃，对“五月风暴”的预感，它根植于现实，某种意义上说，讲的是，讲的是法国长假（les grandes vacances），那是夏天，一群法国学生，主要是资产阶级学生，困在巴黎的一间资产阶级公寓里，并在那里组建了一个毛主义公社。
D'accord. Such 1960s French behavior. The 60s in France was the red decade. It was the decade of le gauchisme, where the sort of fringe left, extreme left began to sort of fragment away from the Parti Communiste, you know, as a completely different way of being on the left, more internationalist. in brackets what's happened in between is in between the second world war and this time i mean is the algerian war which is very little treated subject in french cinema except for except for the the classic um about the battle of algiers yes but that's not french is it or is it french is that it's i hate that, the director of that was Italian, I think, wasn't he? Pontecorvo? I think so.
没错。多么典型的20世纪60年代的法国行为。60年代的法国是红色的十年。那是左翼思潮（le gauchisme）的十年，当时温和左翼、极左翼开始从共产党中分裂出去，你知道的，作为一种截然不同的左翼生存方式，更加国际化。括号里夹叙一下，在这期间发生的事情，在第二次世界大战和这个时期之间，我的意思是阿尔及利亚战争，这是法国电影中极少涉及的主题，除了，除了那部关于阿尔及利亚之战的经典电影……是的，但那不是法国电影，对吧？还是说是法国电影？我讨厌那样，那部电影的导演是意大利人，对吧？蓬特科尔沃（Pontecorvo）？我想是的。
Ah, so that doesn't, that wouldn't count. Okay. Well, there's very, there's a lot of resistance still to telling that story. So that's the whole other, you know,
啊，那就不算数了。好吧。嗯，对于讲述那段历史，仍然存在很大的抵触情绪。所以那是完全另外一回事，你知道的，
the whole colonial story of France is a whole other podcast. And what was the film? Was it Hanukkah? About? Yes, Caché. Caché, yes. About the kind of the missing
法国的整个殖民历史是另一个完全不同的播客话题。那部电影是什么？是《隐藏摄像机》（Caché）吗？关于？是的，《隐藏摄像机》。《隐藏摄像机》，是的。关于那个失踪的
boy. Anyway, we're sorry. But again, told obliquely. So this is a time in the French left, on the French left, where the Communist Party has not been supportive of the Algerian insurrection during the Algerian war. And so
男孩。无论如何，我们很抱歉。但同样是以含蓄的方式讲述。所以这是法国左翼的一个时期，在法国左翼阵营中，共产党在阿尔及利亚战争期间一直不支持阿尔及利亚起义，因此
younger people on the left are very disapproving of that and think that they are revisionists. So the whole film is about, essentially readings from the Little Red Book. You know, they're Maoists. So Mao's Little Red Book is everywhere in the apartment.
左翼的年轻人对此非常不赞同，认为他们是修正主义者。所以整部电影基本上都是关于朗读《毛主席语录》。你知道的，他们是毛主义者。因此毛主席的红宝书在公寓里随处可见。
And the whole thing is styled in a wonderful pop 60s way. You know, Godard loved primary colours. They focus the mind. So the interior of the apartment is painted red and there's blue and yellow and some kind of decibel effect of slogans painted on the walls. There's one that says we must replace confused ideas with clear images for example
整个影片的风格非常具有60年代的流行艺术感。你知道的，戈达尔热爱原色。它们能凝聚注意力。因此公寓的内部被刷成了红色，还有蓝色和黄色，墙上刷着标语，有一种分贝喧嚣的效果。其中一条写着：“我们必须用清晰的图像代替混乱的概念”，例如，
so to what degree is this a serious film is difficult to fathom because in a way Godard
所以这部电影在多大程度上是一部严肃的电影，很难捉摸，因为某种程度上戈达尔
is trying really hard not to be a reactionary he's trying so hard I was asking you about that so this is modelled on Dostoevsky's great novel The Devils The Possessed
在拼尽全力不让自己成为一个反动派，他真的拼尽全力。我之前就是在问你这个；所以这是模仿陀思妥耶夫斯基伟大的小说《群魔》（The Devils / The Possessed），
whatever and Dostoevsky I mean he was the reactionary, The Possessed, whatever. And Dostoevsky, I mean, he was the reactionary. He was very hostile to all this stuff. One of the most, arguably, you could claim, one of the greatest reactionary books ever written. And not just that, Tom. Margaret Thatcher, 10 years after Goddard makes this film, Margaret Thatcher is reading The Possessed,
随便叫什么吧，而陀思妥耶夫斯基，我的意思是，他是个反动派，《群魔》，随便吧。而陀思妥耶夫斯基，我的意思是，他是个反动派。他对所有这些东西都极为敌视。可以说是，你可以宣称这是有史以来最伟大的反动小说之一。不仅如此，汤姆。玛格丽特·撒切尔，在戈达尔拍摄这部电影10年后，玛格丽特·撒切尔正在阅读《群魔》，
or The Devils, call it what you will, and hugely approving of it and saying this is a tremendous warning against the dangers of socialism and stuff. So how is it that, yeah, I mean, I know what you're going to ask. Actually, Tom, you ask a question. Well, I was going to say, why is Godard, who's the man of the left, adapting this unbelievably reactionary novel? It's profounder than that mean it is i it is one of the great novels it's one of and it has this this very very prophetic vision of where leninism and stalinism will go but it's it's it's not a it's not a a novel that a man of the left i i would imagine
或者叫《恶魔》，随你怎么叫，并且极力赞同，说这是一个关于社会主义危险的巨大警告之类的。那么，为什么，是的，我知道你要问什么。其实，汤姆，你来问个问题吧。嗯，我本来想说，为什么身为左翼人士的戈达尔，会去改编这部令人难以置信的反动小说？这比那更深奥，我的意思是，它是一部伟大的小说，它是其中之一，而且它对列宁主义和斯大林主义将走向何方有着非常非常具有预言性的远见，但它并不是一部左翼人士，我想象中
would feel comfortable adapting? Tricky. I think the film, especially with the distance time has passed, is a great example of a kind of double think, to use an Orwellian term, on the part of Godard, is that he is all at once being supportive
会觉得改编起来很舒服的小说？棘手。我认为这部电影，尤其是随着时间流逝带来的距离感，是戈达尔进行“双重思想”（借用奥威尔的一个词）的绝佳例子，即他一方面在支持
of what these young people are trying to do. And among other things, they plan a political assassination, as is the case in the Dostoevsky. And also critical of their endeavour. So, for example, one of the characters, she's called Veronique, who is played by Anne Wierzymski, who was Godard's love interest in real life and was herself a student at Nanterre,
这些年轻人正在尝试做的事情。除其他外，他们计划了一起政治暗杀，就像陀思妥耶夫斯基的小说里那样。而另一方面，他也对他们的努力持批判态度。例如，其中一个角色，她叫韦罗尼克（Veronique），由安妮·维亚泽姆斯基（Anne Wiazemski）扮演，她现实生活中是戈达尔的情人，本人当时也是南泰尔大学的学生，
the hotbed of where May 68 was going to explode at the time. She says, I can't really connect with the working classes, you know, because after all, my parents are bankers, she says in the film. And there is also a wonderful scene where there's a traveling shot that travels through three or four windows, you know, shot on the balcony, looking into the flat. And so at the left hand side of the room, a Maoist activist, a real life Maoist activist called, what was his name? Omar Diop, I think a Senegalese man, is lecturing the others about essentially the class struggle. He's reading from the Little Red Book. And then the camera travels to the middle of the room
那是后来“五月风暴”即将爆发的温床。她在电影里说：“我真的无法与工人阶级建立联系，你知道的，因为毕竟，我的父母是银行家。”电影中还有一个精彩的场景，是一个横摇镜头，穿过了三扇或四扇窗户（你知道的，镜头从阳台上拍摄，向屋内张望）。所以在房间的左侧，一个毛主义激进分子，一个现实生活中的毛主义激进分子，叫什么名字来着？奥马尔·迪奥普（Omar Diop），我想是一个塞内加尔人，正在向其他人宣讲阶级斗争的本质。他正在读红宝书。然后镜头移动到房间中央，
where there's a huge pile of Little Red Books and the others are sitting around it, smoking, listening, taking part in the debate. And then the final window we look through shows a character called Yvonne, who is the proletarian character in the group. So she's not like the others, a pampered sort of bubblegum revolutionary. She's from the countryside.
那里有一大堆红宝书，其他人围坐在四周，抽烟、倾听、参与辩论。接着，我们通过最后一扇窗户看到一个叫伊冯娜（Yvonne）的角色，她是群体中的无产阶级代表。所以她不像其他人那样，是个被宠坏的、嚼着泡泡糖的革命者。她来自农村。
She finds it very difficult to connect with all the complicated concepts that the others talk about. And what she does in that scene is clean shoes. So she's cleaning shoes while they're listening to the lecture. And throughout the film, she's always working. She's washing up, making tea. She even turns to prostitution to fund the commune. That's a very Godard situation to find yourself in, I think. So Godard is at once, I'd say, really politically obtuse. I mean, throughout his career, I would say he really is. And at the same time, he's not without humour and irony and distance. That's perhaps why he can't really make a didactic movie in the way that he would like to.
她发现自己很难理解其他人谈论的那些复杂的概念。而在那个场景中，她做的事是擦鞋。所以当他们在听讲座时，她在擦鞋。而在整部电影中，她总是在干活。她在洗碗、泡茶。她甚至为了资助公社而去卖淫。我认为，这是一种非常戈达尔式的处境。所以戈达尔一方面，我要说，在政治上真的很迟钝。我的意思是，纵观他的整个职业生涯，我觉得他确实如此。与此同时，他又并非缺乏幽默感、讽刺感和距离感。这或许就是为什么他无法真正拍出一部他所希望的那种说教式电影。
Yeah. OK, well, didactic movies, that's everything that we want from France. Well, you clearly don't, Tom, because you liked that film with Terry Thomas in it. Yeah, I loved it. I loved it. of course the other the other great film about uh the Algerian war Day of the Jackal yes Day of the Jackal yeah um so uh just a couple of questions before we before we um wind up uh so Muriel the French film industry I mean my my sense of it is that it's it's it's always felt a bit embattled by Hollywood um Is it still alive and well independently, or is it increasingly threatened by, you know, US streaming services and all those kinds of things?
是的。好吧，说教式的电影，这就是我们对法国的一切期待。嗯，你显然不是，汤姆，因为你喜欢那部有特里·托马斯的电影。是的，我很喜欢。我非常喜欢。当然，另一部，另一部关于阿尔及利亚战争的伟大电影是《豺狼的日子》（The Day of the Jackal），是的，《豺狼的日子》，是的。所以，呃，在我们，在我们结束之前有几个问题。所以，穆里尔，法国电影产业，我的感觉是，它总是让人觉得受到好莱坞的围剿。它是依然独立且充满活力，还是越来越受到美国流媒体服务以及诸如此类事情的威胁？
It is. I mean, everyone's threatened by US streaming services, but the French have quite successfully, are quite successfully making content for their own streaming services. So there are, they they understood you know that perhaps most people now will not be going to the cinema as habitually as they used to that they'll be watching things on television and streaming things so there are lots of dramas there's something like le bureau des légendes for example which
确实如此。我的意思是，每个人都受到美国流媒体服务的威胁，但法国人相当成功地，正在相当成功地为他们自己的流媒体服务制作内容。所以他们有，他们明白，你知道的，也许现在大多数人不会像过去那样习惯去电影院了，他们会在电视上观看节目并进行流媒体点播，所以有很多电视剧，比如像《传奇办公室》（Le bureau des légendes）这样的作品，
is the one about the Secret Service, the French Secret Service, which is great, really a wonderful production and is set in Paris, but also takes part in Syria, Algeria, other sort of hotbeds of political unrest. I think there's been quite a successful adaptation to that
讲的是特工部门，法国情报部门，非常棒，真的是一部精彩的制作，故事设定在巴黎，但也涉及叙利亚、阿尔及利亚等其他政治动荡的热点地区。我认为法国人已经相当成功地适应了这一点，
and to creating French language product that people are going to want to consume, not necessarily as feature films, but as things that you can stream. And the other question I had was, so if our listeners only have time to watch one film, I mean, that's tragic. So just one film, what is the film
并且成功创作出了人们想要消费的法语内容，不一定非要作为故事片，而是作为你可以流媒体点播的内容。我问的另一个问题是，如果我们的听众只有时间看一部电影——这太悲剧了——那么仅凭一部电影，究竟是哪一部
they absolutely have to watch otherwise they can be only one yeah i'm going to be um a little stern and i'm going to pick a black and white movie because i think you can never recommend black and white movies enough people must watch more yeah and so for me it is the children of paradise because it is so unusual and so perfect as a vision of Frenchness. That would be my choice. But Muriel, would there not be a case for saying that Les Enfants du Paradis is the best film, but Ridicule is the best film about history. Oh, Tom!
他们绝对非看不可，否则就只能二选一了？是的，我要变得，呃，稍微严格一点，我要挑选一部黑白电影，因为我觉得你再怎么推荐黑白电影都不为过，人们必须多看黑白电影。所以对我和《天堂的孩子》（Children of Paradise）来说，它是如此不同寻常，作为法国性的一种愿景又是如此完美。这就是我的选择。但穆里尔，难道没有理由说《天堂的孩子》是最好的电影，而《华丽的假期 / 嘲笑》（Ridicule）是关于历史的最好电影吗？哦，汤姆！
What has ridicule got on you? It's so good. Honestly, it's the best film about history ever made. Whereas Les Enfants du Paradis, as a film about history, is slightly sentimental, perhaps. Yes. Un petit peu, I don't know. Un petit peu sentimentale. No, yes, yes, yes. There's a case to be made.
《嘲笑》有什么好？它太棒了。说真的，这是有史以来关于历史的最佳电影。而《天堂的孩子》作为一部历史电影，可能稍微有点多愁善感。是的。有一点（Un petit peu），我不知道。有一点多愁善感（Un petit peu sentimentale）。不，是的，是的，是的。这确实有争论的余地。
It's an impossible question. There's a case to be made for ridicule. There's a case to be made for all of these films. That's the idea. I tried to select things. It's a brilliant choice. It all depends on the mood. You know, La Grande Vedrouille equally,
这是一个无法回答的问题。支持《嘲笑》有它的道理。支持所有这些电影都有各自的道理。这就是重点。我试图挑选一些作品。这是一个精彩的选择。这一切都取决于当时的心情。你知道的，《虎口脱险》同样如此，
it would be a shame not to have seen that. Yeah. Well, it's a fact. They were brilliant choices. It's a fantastic list. and i think a wonderful format um so thank you so much for suggesting it uh and and for compiling the list and coming on and talking about them so so wonderfully and uh i hope that i hope that everyone's enjoyed it and um you know happy viewing because there are some absolute miles yeah go out and watch some French films. Especially go and watch Ridiculous.
没看过那部电影会是一种遗憾。是的。嗯，事实上，这些都是极好的选择。这是一个梦幻般的片单，而且我认为这种形式棒极了。所以非常感谢你提出这个建议，感谢你整理这个片单，并以如此精彩的方式前来畅谈。我希望，我希望每个人都听得开心，呃，你知道的，祝观影愉快，因为这里面有一些绝对的经典。是的，快去看看法国电影吧。特别是去看《嘲笑》。
It's also, by some way, I think the shortest. Yeah. Merci beaucoup, Muriel. Merci à vous. Merci à vous, the listeners. And we will see you all next time. Au revoir. Au revoir.
在某种程度上，我认为它也是最短的。谢谢你，穆里尔。谢谢你。谢谢你们，听众们。我们下次再见。再见。再见。
Au revoir. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见。感谢收听《历史就是这样》（The Rest Is History）。想要获取独家单集、提前收听权限、无广告体验以及加入我们的聊天社区，请登录 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。也就是 therestisentertainment.com。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。